all right I've got everything set up am
i and we are in twitch and get the green
light will count it down for the last
Ward number 64
all right go in three two all right we
love the last word with boxes and
special guests we got oh man we do we do
very excited to have our special guests
here today but I'm not the one who
handles the intros that one I will pass
back to you sir it is the last word we
got a lot of destiny to talk about today
as always thank you guys for jumping in
to chat but the man of the introductions
is here so I'm gonna go ahead and put my
mic to the side and let him handle his
his business that's what he's known for
let's get to it
welcome to the last word episode number
64 that's not a glorious Friday and
we're back in front of the campfire for
some looters shooter discussion I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests so we gonna get right into it I
want to introduce a lord who's positive
mindset the passion for the destiny
franchise is truly a sight to behold
whether it be his extreme detail weapon
and armor reviews or its willingness to
help others in the community dis Lord in
my opinion represents the epitome of
cool introducing the creator and host of
the cool guy YouTube and twitch channels
the lord of getting you in a proper
mindset to succeed and one of the very
few guardians to keep the crucible flag
raised high with his love of pvp laughs
for Missouri and kind enough to make his
debut within the realm of the last word
mahmud cool guy are you doing sir no I'm
good good morning guys how are you doing
great glad to have you in here man
absolutely well it is gonna be a fun
morning this morning so we've got quite
a bit to talk about but just to get
going tell everybody I'm sure a lot of
people already know but if they don't
I'll let them know kind of what you do
what's your contents all about kind of
what got you into the world of destiny
and we'll just start with you man
so my channels mostly around I first
started it way back when and I started
making videos with my xbox right I
didn't have a capture card I didn't have
anything like that and I just wanted to
say like five things on YouTube because
I felt like I could help players just be
a little bit better at the game enjoy
the game a little bit more doing that
and people liked what I had to say and
ultimately I just kept going and going
planted destiny way back when when
they're like 400,000 subscribers no
notice they said hey you know we like
you to make some content so I was like
well you know a cheat capture card and a
computer that like it literally took
seven hours to render a video like oh my
god
I know the field it was so bad upgrade
but oh man like at night I would try to
render this video and hopefully wake up
and please just don't let it crash right
like that now that was where I was but
yeah I had a passion for it and you know
now of course I've told my hundred oh
god oh and all that no no you see you
know I I'd be weapon reviews and I do
armor reviews but it all started on that
basis of like crucible tips and I'm now
starting to get back into that on my
channel I love it to death in a destiny
man's Bungie he would like through and
through Xbox guy right I play on xbox oh
you know mommy the main even free that
made breach and then look right and they
gave the rights over to Microsoft and
three or three I didn't really like Halo
4 unfortunately I'm a huge Halo fan but
we kind of found out that working on
this game called destiny so I feel
personally that no one makes the
first-person sheer like Bungie man like
[Applause]
[Laughter]
movement and you know I mean we got
space magic like it's a phenomenal
experience dude so what better time to
start making YouTube then you know a
franchise in a world I'd like to be a
part of right so absolutely absolutely
good stuff man a lot of good history and
yeah I mean one thing I really
appreciate you about you I know we spoke
off arm off air which is that like your
attention to detail but also
mindset like you kind of when you do
your reviews it's really cool because
it's like sometimes these things that I
personally think are useless I'm like
yeah don't you know this exact I can't
reverse whole whatever if you're not
watch your video in conference hall and
I'm seeing how effective you are with it
just mindset and spacing and I'm like
alright I gotta use it cuz cool guy said
it's cool
it's me effective yeah you're really
good at that man really good
first hold rocks dude whoa I don't know
why everybody was saying that things
suck Sara it was bad things awesome oh
it was just your recent video the one on
just a PvP the improve your k/d guide
your third one that you had recently in
the last couple days I think just your
movement and spacing and what it's
either the intro section or later on
when you're talking about it I'll watch
you go through this like hunter doesn't
pop your Golden Gun hit two people in
the face turn to the other side and I'm
going damn so it's like I was just like
I want to be like cool guy like what if
you like Mike over there so no just
watching the movement and stuff like
that and I honestly I started as a
hunter and d1 and then when Kings fall
came out or king fault yeah taking King
came out I honestly took went to my
Titan have been more Titan but then I
watched the mobility on that hunter and
I'm like I reason there's a reason they
kicked my butt in PvP and just watching
you do that I'm like damn so now it's
it's impressive to watch a skilled
player and you you do it in a very calm
collected way you're detailed as he's
saying like the detail that you put into
each piece you don't miss any aspect of
whatever your review and is it this is a
PvP is a PvE is it good here should you
probably be doing this like all these
little things you take into account that
will show off basically I almost feel
like you are like okay who made this
weapon or piece of armor at Bungie how
can I show it off the best because
you're gonna give it as much love as
like whoever mate who created the thing
in the first place probably wanted it to
get and they're sitting over there like
thank you cool guy appreciate you giving
some love to my piece of armor because
somebody's not liking it so no I
appreciate ya it's great to watch and
your climb has been awesome to watch and
can't wait to see you crack over a
hundred thousand in no time I'm sure
you'll be there so what's there man
we're almost there it could be next year
maybe next month I don't care we're just
gonna go along with it do you but like
when I play like if you look at my top
five weapons overall like it's just it's
just so scattered well I'm probably like
150,000 Crucible cuz like I play a lot
of crucible but I don't really like
Lunas Herald or not forgotten they're
what they're pushed way down it's kind
of weird things like flash and thunders
on my top five mm okay they go shot
grenade launcher like it's just oddball
things that would I make content right
so especially with like the double
primary meta you guys remember that oh
yeah yo Barry let me tell you on console
that's tough
using huckleberry against like your eels
gift on that back there but I'll use if
like five you know ten days and just try
to make a video on it and buffers trying
to you know get good content out of it
but I use a wide variety because every
single one even the blue guns every
single gun in destiny I have shot right
good like I'll I just how they work it
doesn't matter if it's blue or a
legendary or an exotic I just I love it
to death yeah that's what I like about
you because we're obviously I'm not
challenging you with all these variety
of weapons but the thing that's cool is
that like I'm a person that likes to go
against the grain so if the meta is
something like back in the day with the
uros gift and all that stuff and then
obviously there are Lunas house stuff
I'm the person trying to find effective
counters or other weapons as well in
that type of medical side I just don't
like doing what everyone else is gonna
you know any kind of thing and that's
again another reason why I appreciate
you because you do show their
practicality yeah one of my favorite
loadouts I mean it's on console it's
probably different piece yeah I love
like a monarch a tube combo mmm it's so
deadly on console oh man oh my god I
read it in conf you'd like I'll run
dropped a game I'm at about 3000 comps
for haven't lost and I've been running
Khepri sting monarch a Duke like it
could be done I'm telling you like so oh
yeah oh yeah what's that dual role real
quick what was that role on that Duke
was that robot rapid hit rampage nice
rapid is beautiful or do covet okay I
have like five of those can you tell me
which one I should keep
you know so you can stop warding I see
so I have a vault problem so that's a
whole different issue rapid kill clip
rapid hit rampage and like there's rapid
hit a opening shot right the cool thing
about the high impacts rampage is once
you get the kill
mmm it starts doing a hundred of the
head so you start to tapping people so
all you have to do with Monarch cuz I
run a decent damage no matter what once
you get a headshot you're just gonna get
a one headshot clean up kill the next
guys a two taps so there's a rampage
mode on there so you have five seconds
to search for the second guy mm-hm
to run it so it's cool to Mon art
because the poison damage because if you
hit him in the head you can hit him with
the body of the Duke if you had the
monarch in the body yeah I wouldn't
either so on so far it's seems to happen
all day long basically and it sounds
quite effective mm-hmm Duke cake like a
truck - oh yeah I will say anybody who
like consistently uses a bow I would say
as someone you should fear typically
there was I forget it was like a gambit
mad at I was running around it was like
gambit know it was comp not even game it
was comp and there was a point where I
went up and it's PC so the player base
isn't the biggest couple ties times I
came across like a pair of guys and they
were running both using bows I was like
you're using comp at like fabled level
I'm should be scared like because if
you're using a bow at that level I need
to turn and run cuz you are skilled if
you're actually choosing to use it at
that level so that's that's talent right
there so a man on console I can only
mention this even harder to hold the
trigger and then get that like pull at
the right time so I'm sure you can't you
can't really challenge bows man if
you're like in a lane and they hate you
you can't pop out you're done like no a
lot of control man mm-hmm
I can hit you in the toe after that
first shot you're toast so well yeah so
well happy to have you here with us
yeah honestly just looking forward to
watching you continue to grow and
obviously looking forward to meet you at
Guardian Conchas we will be there too so
yeah that is gonna be that is gonna be a
week late from today actually it starts
almost be going live I think it opens at
like 10:00 it opens up but it'll be
Friday next week
so how many Guardian counts have you
been to a cool guy cuz I know we're all
kind of different in attendance here
this is my third year straight nice mmm
oh it's my first one and I'm never not
coming put it that way yes we said we
met on one three years ago so it'll be
as a three or four there were two in the
middle I haven't done so this would be
so they've been fourth
this feels now that sounds weird but
yeah I'm us two in the middle from after
we met right and you know I've been to
one after the way I met you okay I've
been to two totally and this one will be
my third nice yeah the first you was uh
daddy fat snaps and bones you guys
remember that one yeah that must have
been the one you went to I think cuz
that would've been the year I did yep
yep that was when I went to daddy
festival Tony they had the arcade
machines there's old Tampa Fairgrounds
yeah good stuff yeah we got an upgrade
so yeah the Rosen Shingle Creek this
Resort we're going to man it's seriously
like everything is there it's all
indoors which is amazing like it's all
walking distance so I know like we'll be
there a couple days afterwards for sure
cuz my wife and I are gonna hang out go
to like Universal one day we're gonna do
as much Harry Potter stuff as we came in
one day and then I think the other day
we might just show but like what do you
guys are you guys getting the extra time
out there I think yeah yours is yeah I
was like cool guy hey uh can you hear me
all right yeah lead up getting a condo
on a lake dude and I really enjoyed
fishing oh nice haha I read some I live
like here's a deal man cuz it's like a
30-second walk down Lake I'm gonna go
straight to like a sporting store grab
fishing rod like that's gonna be my
thing for a little bit she wants to
Universal we did that last year and
that's a
all in itself dude nice or like the big
thing is going to Epcot for 4th of July
like I'm really considering that
everyone says that's that's a damn nice
I could see that being and saying we get
in it like six oh I have no idea what
it'd be like to get in check-in and
still trying to get over there I'm sure
it's just absolute bonkers but the be
insane Sunday we're doing halo outpost
Oh know if you guys are doing that well
you said that I didn't know it was going
on concurrently yeah I was thinking
about it cuz I don't what do I have
enough time because it's writing that
that window what day what there you are
are you going me what time yarn so we'll
probably get there first thing Sunday
morning cuz the Colin's Friday Saturday
right and go out those Saturday Sunday
but a prote said be like I think I like
on Groupon you can go and get like 20%
off over here like Google and stuff in
the podcast and say what what's going on
cool give an outsider Destin you know
I'm loving this yeah man I mean and I
would hope that some of the Bungie devs
go to that oh there's no way they don't
I feel like yeah I'm sure they will be
all over that type of stuff it's their
gate I mean that's their what's their
other major baby that they've made so
yeah they definitely got to go see a few
of them will I'm sure how long their
trip is though because I know they did
the community outreach thing for pulling
a couple people into the next community
summit and that thing starts like real
fast so there's not a lot of downtime I
guess for some of them I guess we'll see
how much they have yeah there's so I've
never been to Bungie I plan to go one
day I want to do a studio to our man
because it is it's just so cool
you and needles yeah yeah that's like on
a bucket list for me too absolutely
and that's that's the hope I mean I
don't know you're big enough some point
I feel like you'll get the shoulder to
the little tap on the shoulder and be
like hey you want to come to this summit
we want your opinion sir Oh we'll see me
like so what's cool about like cuz
there's so many good a my opinion like
community leaders they just recently
what I'm budging that and read it to
take people from each one of those
sections to go
the summit up coming up which is great
yeah and I know a lot of people get
upset like well they don't invite just
the average person and now they are
which is great yeah and content creators
man I tell you what like video and I'll
have 800 thousand comments so like and I
read them all and I'm sure like the big
people you know your true bad guards see
they get a lot more they read those so
like feel on what how their community
feels right so bite it out either you
might be yeah you might be cutting in
and out of the way kind of now just a
little bit is that better
yep yeah so far sounds Clara mmm-hmm say
let me know yeah well maybe one day for
me but you know a lot of content
creators kind of I mean they follow the
game obviously and they have a good
pulse on how their community feels like
I have a discord man and I made that on
a whim just to help players find games
to try to get lunes Howell know what I
do I never used this chord in my entire
life dude this thing looks pretty cool
right this little discord thing so I
made this thing made it I put it in the
video I said hey you know we're gonna do
this specifically to find games because
I know finding games are going as a solo
player can be rough and it's a lot
easier I mean even if it's just me like
the connection that you guys have as me
at least you have something to talk
about and hopefully guys can become
friends and start writing some comp
together right mm-hmm and 2500 people
are there okay yes wow that's awesome
oh I had to get admins like I did sit up
toilet
anytime anybody said anything everyone
got a ping right so like everyone's
phones that I have like you know 8000
notifications it's alright I'm gonna
figure this out now it's too big I do
alright so and I have some great mods in
there and I have some great I mean it's
in just great discussions and now it's
over like 4000 people and it's just kind
of my thing I didn't think it would be a
thing but it's a thing it's awesome
that's really cool man it's cool then
seeing that growth that I think I
actually joined you
cuz it had I remember when you put that
out okay buddy you needs any help and
you had a couple of rules open I'm like
jumping eggs I was trying to get the
balloons grind on Xbox at the town oh
yeah that grind was a pain I'd let think
that invitation for kicking me off and
then I'd up getting just spending way
too much time and comp after that so
I've never been as much of a comp player
I know
cognitive us over there just like come
on come on let's go that's that's my jam
let's get in there love it I love it and
it was that last invitation of nine
where you had to do the rumble quick
play and competitive I play the three
competitive I was like yes like I know
I'm on like the low man totem pole like
zero glory score let's try and then I
jumped in and I ended up getting like a
five streak between like a few extra
matches probably than that and I was
that like a thousand I'm like bull crap
I'm halfway to fabled so then I actually
started looking for I was like okay now
I got to figure out see if there's any
places out there and I think it was CG
he posted about his server too so I
ended up jumping in his because I must
have missed your memo and just jumped in
there had a little help on two different
set sessions and ended up getting it but
it was like now I'm like now I'm kind of
got like the itch for comp now it's like
it takes a little bit to get into and
sometimes it is definitely absolutely
brutal and when I was forgetting like
I'd played some games with CG and it was
just like on their team I'm just like I
would be the solo guy I know if I
wouldn't have been with him going
against them just watching my glory go
down quicker and quicker so it's like
that's where I would have been but then
it's like if you can get some help and
play together it's like kid it's like
comp is cool and that's one thing you
said like for a shooter when the space
magic is flying and everything is kind
of at it's like at the peak and things
are going and you're talking and you're
in those moments it's still hard to
compete with this game even in something
where it's like I know people want
trials and things aren't perfect but man
there are some moments in this game
there's just like can't really get
touched by too much else it's so much
fun I think a good point in conjunction
what you said is you stand like you know
when I watch you know cool guys video I
do you got to be a reference to um you
know as far as what needs to happen
wacom you know and just PvP in general
and I know match was a focus to some
other thing
but one yeah one of the things he said
is really close if you're playing right
now you truly love PvP you don't say
like you truly look at obviously it's
not in the space that it needs to be so
again you got they got that foundation
and again if they go course correct it
just add the things that the community
is wanting and you know hopefully we'll
get a little bit of that without a
shadow keep it could you know it could
really rise again because we all know
you know what trials did for it back in
the past and just some basic structure
edges yeah it would be really really
good to see so I wanted actually ask you
since we're kind of on this topic anyway
and it seems very perfect or just like
stick this one in here
so in the fall they talked about like
obviously PvP they've even acknowledged
like the kind of neglect for maps and
modes and changes and things like that
so when they say they want to work on
playlists and kind of foundational type
stuff as kind of what it seems they've
alluded to in the fall what are things
for you like what are your kind of top
three things that you want to see and
you may have said this already in the
video but it's gonna quick rundown that
you would see like little make a PvP
experience better for you both PC
console
I mean cross David all that stuff is
great but it's like what's gonna make
that PvP take it to the next level that
you want to come along with all the
other stuff we got coming so it depends
on what route they go because I mean
they specifically said that this next
season is gonna have a lot of crucible
in it right mm-hmm
well thought process was I mean it's
been eight months nine months a year and
if you're not really going to give it a
love at least give something back a
little bit and like I'm to the point I
think a lot of players are is like I was
talking about the maps like bring back
widows court bring back arrested yeah
it's like just pour them right over I
mean I they're different engines and
they have to use some stuff to it but
like the assets are they're just kind of
remake it in we're happy just do that
right but I mean it sounds like they're
doing that we saw widows court in the in
the thigh dock mm-hmm they're bringing
back elimination I was a big deal for me
like when they talk about competitive
destiny and you know what was really
nice about iron banner and let's just
kind of jump off real quick I mean iron
banner is the first time and sp2 that a
PvP activity grants enhanced armor yes
yes and it kind of went unnoticed
so obviously that's the armor in the
game you'd get it from raids you get it
from reckoning things like that but
there never was any kind of activity so
that like to me that kind of showed me
okay maybe that they're starting to pay
a little attention to it right right if
that's an entirely different community
like as an example my wife uh she's you
know believe or not she's pretty good at
games right she's she's over to Katie
and Call of Duty right so she just some
issues because she she strictly loves
the crucible she doesn't really she
hates jumping puzzles like that's not
her jam so like all the D rates of
course her focus on jumping puzzles like
my brother mm-hmm
he's like I'm done just do it for me
should I put the guitar sounds like we
need to get you on a blast furnace we
need to get you out of bygone so you on
console you'd really like it she's like
but I got to play gibbet right so it's
like she's like just powering through
gambit right so there are people that
just love PvP and I know like a lot of
people might ask or like they play it 95
or so of the time they don't even have
some of the best guns because they just
don't go into PvE that's their thing
it's unfortunately there's not a good PD
content the game like I love PvE and I
just don't cover that much on my channel
but no back back to that main question
oh no no you're in the perfect place
like when you want to talk about
tangents and offshoots and like wrong
talks 4:30 yeah you're in a good spot
you're you're totally [ __ ] so there is
a PvP community right and way back in
the day they had like the MLG tournament
I'm if you guys remember that like
luminosity yes like I honestly believe
that there's always been an interest an
interest for like higher in destiny play
so like the ring back elimination and to
me like if they were ever to bring back
trials it needs to be 3 B 3 elimination
talk about it let's go I was like I you
gotta get it rolling let's talk about it
right now three elimination
it's more of a what's word I'm looking
for like like a closer team comp of
three players for before but there's a
lot of things to me that needs to change
they've already talked
right reducing super health heavy Allen
needs to be addressed when I'm the point
of one of my big things that I hope
today changes heavy ammo and just one
time a game everybody had fun
everyone goes to the thing 60 mole and
quick play or one round anybody have fun
for 15 seconds and then it's over
because in destiny too I mean if you
haven't noticed if you on the crucible
you'll be on a great streak and all of a
sudden out of nowhere I'm like okay
you're in your spawn with rockets I
don't know how that happened but it did
hmm
it's just me just little things like
that they can touch out of course you
know fix and recoil on console ya know
ya big town let me back you up a second
Oh mcg because um I wanted to ask you
about what you specifically mentioned
rev3 elimination and me and you are on
the same exact place for that right but
I want to get to the part about Bungie
store process remember they came out
with it swab and they were like look you
know in this day and age as of right now
you know when people are clamoring for
trials they were saying that they don't
feel that it would translate well and I
got to be honest what you see like I
struggled with that comment because part
of me is saying you know this is when
destiny was kind of at its pinnacle PvP
and that was you know streamers and the
community was behind it and you know you
had your boons and you're going through
the whole English you know Charles
Harris so it's like I guess like how did
you feel personally when you heard that
statement and then if they're not gonna
bring it back in that form what else
could they do to kind of bring trials to
that level again thought about it see if
right when they said that because I'm
thinking trials and destiny one KEB
destiny going alright superfan over here
mmm
80 hundred thousand twitch viewers right
for crafty and like luminosity and all
these people because what's so cool
about trials is a player and the PvE
player not even talking about streaming
because you know I like on my side I'd
have some really strong PvE players
helped me out with raids well I mean let
me take you through trials right so like
it's like you do this for me I'll do
exactly they got exchanged even if he
didn't really like it was really fun to
watch so I started thinking they made
trials in destiny too for before they
had like little intros but there was
things like countdown right then it was
you know primary versus primary and I've
always wondered like how it would be
introduced with you know the system we
have now but mm-hm
they have Vicarious Visions and other
studios if I carry visions did a lot for
this game like I don't think like they
made more mine they made so many
different things for destiny too so I'm
thinking well bungees got to be working
on something right at some point for
being real here destiny kind of fell off
mm-hmm
for sake and brought it back just way
back today like taking King right right
I think that their separate communities
PvE and PvP if they were just bringing
trials back let's say tomorrow mm-hmm it
wouldn't do justice for the game like it
would make the could be ready happy
right is they need to bring it back with
something like forsaken right don't keep
coming up it it needs to be a huge
expansion or like like I said they're
having this you know cross save stadia
no I'm a whole bunch it's like that's
when they need to drop it because they
can't just do it now my opinion it would
be a failing thing completely agree
completely agree so so you can follow up
with that when convenient
II have had this question you know he
pros he posed it to me like wit shadow
keep with so much going on you know
obviously like you said cross save and
you know all these new features and
stuff like that and new light and the
population will be high you know is it
asking too much you think at for shadow
key or maybe we have to wait but like
the next part of the annual pass before
we get trials again I think it'd be way
way later on dude
because and they made a commitment and
saying you know what our studio can make
you know seasons of content coming up
with the next Annual Pass right like I
said before like those studios did a lot
and like they did so much like I
remember looking back and I forget what
it was for you but like an earlier early
destiny want like 2014-2015 concept
our Mars looks exactly like Venus now if
that makes sense but basically what
happened is is Vicarious Visions came
along and they made Mars and with their
Mars as they made it Venus so if you
look at the concept art for destiny one
its Venus but Brown braids nice so weird
how it all went down right and the whole
Activision thing but I I think that
they're gonna commit to building their
promises now of you know getting content
out like they're getting ready to come
out with the moon like they need to get
all that done before they put something
like that on their on their plate in my
opinion yeah so I had asked kognito as
well kind of curious your thoughts on
this one so the way the seasons have
gone previously yeah there's a lot of
questions I can ask you will see how
many we get to but this will be one so
the way the seasons have gone we had
black armor in the Forge and that was
kind of PvE then we had season drifter
which was mostly gambit and then we had
obviously opulence was kind of back to
more PvE if they did some cadence like
that again how do you think the overall
do you think it would be like fitting
fair good better otherwise if they did a
season say it was like shadow keep
another season and then say like your
March or your spring time where drifter
landed if it was like a season of trials
like do you think that would actually
how do you think that would go over and
do you think that would be a decent
place to let it let it land is it at the
red Jax y'all good storyline with the
red Jack I gotta be honest though it's
higher as that would be for us because
we love our PvP now one of the negatives
to season of The Drifter was that it was
so gambits focus and if you didn't like
gambit that season one for you so do you
think they can get away I mean will be
smiling means you will be like it happen
I don't think so man it would have to be
an add-on just like trials have to be
that on like it had to be with something
yeah because I think if they have a
whole season is just PvP people all
right I'll see each face you've like ha
ha
yeah I'm getting better about this I'd
be on board I've slowly been working on
my sniper kills a lot less lower than a
lot of people for my slow kills and I'll
work on a revoke her but it'll happen
eventually so like are doing the buy in
model for the seasons and the pass
itself I'm obviously gonna get all the
seasons I love the game right but what I
do if you haven't noticed when they're
done with content they're done but what
hope one day they get to a point as are
to where the like it'll take black arm I
do like I like black army it was the
first time you could R actually select a
weapon go in farm said weapon
yes engines black army comes out then we
have season the drafter in net word
opulence and opulence is amazing what if
you know seas of opulence comes out you
see the patch notes and like okay rifle
to black armory right we added this
styopa rifle like as all these seasons
go on like those are such good things
right I think black are very such a good
thing for the game like why not add a
couple weapons to that with the content
drop they're getting ready to do that
that gives you reason to go back to the
forges does that make sense I see
exactly yeah I mean though Cognito
you've been playing black army right now
haven't you I've been playing a lot of
black armory it's so funny he said that
because um like I said I got in I got
into a little late and I started I
started working on on certain quests and
you know they but what it is is be
honest with the real reason why I won't
get back into it I'm a type of person
that like to have diversified weapons
you know whenever so that that whenever
the meta changes I'm prepared so if the
matter goes one way okay boom I got my
blast furnace God role here I got this
going on here I got my if is it now me
you know with it with the catalyst now
you know I'm ready to go so if anything
in the metal shifts I got something as a
backup so that was primarily my reason
for playing but as I'm doing it and I'm
seeing I'm like yeah I like like like CG
said like I like being able to grind
specifically for what I want like that
gameplay loop and then going to the fort
it's actually cool it's it's a you know
kind of mindless activity jump in there
you don't you know you don't really need
matchmaking just three you know and kind
of knock yourself out so I like it you
know I personally like you know I think
it's it's something your suggestion is
actually something very cool I would
actually like as well yeah man all these
past seasons I hope they add on to you
but I know they they have a lot on their
plate I think that they did a good job
for everything that's going on do you
like their the captains of their own
ship now with Activision being gone if
you haven't noticed I mean Luke Smith's
making blog post like mm-hmm
a lot of people talk in the Dever talk
for yes it's refreshing you saw her from
the Vidocq like what suitors do fit out
Cattrall me and ii we noticed it amelia
right ii we were just like man like you
you can you can sense it you can sense
them being themselves and in molding
destiny the way they wanted the minute
they talked about no more exclusive
content anymore and everyone playing
together all-inclusive love to talk man
that's that's the most exciting thing
man like i think that the true vision of
destiny is getting ready to come out
over the next you know year and at least
the blueprint of it and you know they
said they want to touch on it for 2-3
more years and maybe destiny 3 it
doesn't really matter as long as they
keep updating the game the community is
very very passionate about the game and
you know people are talking about you
know des and he said this isn't gonna
die dude like no in like so anthem came
out that was opposed to a destiny killer
existed like so a lot of I have friends
that still play anthem to I was looking
the other day there's like 280 total
players on xbox or hath up like it's
it's horrendous but I never hate on
someone for like in a game right I mean
that's what gave me for its you know
it's a hobby it's a passion and if you
like something dude you know rock on but
like that's me it like with what they're
doing I think it's it's gonna have
longevity right so I'm pretty excited
for what what they're getting ready to
do one last point I'll jump on what you
said is that um
you're so right because you know I've
seen it you know social media as soon as
the next big game comes out we hear it
all the time
destiny killer right and to me I'm like
easy don't do that to that game he does
that we've seen it like division is
probably the closest right now is
or as I feel competing but at the end of
the day and II we've talked about all
the time when it comes down to that gun
claim right Lila Webb just basic
fundamentals and then you know even now
you see division eight doing a raid and
they're having their little issues and
stuff like that far as balancing things
like that but there's one thing you know
to be doing something like a raid to say
you're doing it and then there's another
thing to actually execute and then have
that fictional world where it kind of
makes sense and it's just the mechanics
are just on another level so it to me
what I realized that even at kanji when
they're at their lowest of destiny's at
its lowest the core gameplay is so good
that's why we remain loyal to the game
you don't say it's just it's just so
good so I think it's one of those things
that let's stay completely you know
screw up and say after their community
do something crazy which I don't
envision having especially now they're
on their own from the--from Activision
you know the future's bright and I think
we get maybe by d3 we get um you know
cross play you know I'm saying now we're
getting cross save you know I think
next-gen and whatever you know it's
gonna be really exciting times for the
future and look at the Play account
right over one oh yeah active people are
excited is this game no matter how many
times it's down it always rises back
it's cool to see they're pretty smart
about it too man so there's there's a
whole bunch of stuff that probably
happened behind closed doors with
Activision that we'll never know and
honestly I mean that's that's their deal
but it feels like it looks like the
email the whole game was kind of held
down because of that partnership right
and they needed that partnership which
is weird because they're with Microsoft
one of the biggest publishers in the
world so now we're good we're gonna go
to Activision because activation has the
reach Activision good PlayStation and
then they did PC right with Blizzard yes
so now they leave Activision to part
over Studios like it's just kind of
weird how they all do it but it's all
for the growth of the game like stadia
is gonna be huge
mm-hmm I think now they're in a position
to where the game could actually start
thriving with their vision and I think
they did a good job absolutely man II
know we're just kind of hitting random
stuff as we kind of go through so I know
we've got shadow keep coming to the fall
with a lot of stuff for you are there
any May
changes that you've seen weather I mean
I don't mind there were a couple things
just when they were doing the viaduct
and I think as you guys were saying it
too before the viaduct even started that
stream when it was just Luke and Mark
talking and I think that was the part
where he was just there feeling of just
like candid hey we're shooting this
stuff with you right now we're going
through these bullet points I've got my
list and like Luke's just being all like
those two talking when they're talking
it's like they seem like the perfect
pair to keep each other in check
losing Luke is just like you know just
kind of has like fun marks like he's
gonna like hit down his bullet points
and those two kind of like mark seems
like he may keep Luke in check Luke
probably has mark think out of the box
and stuff like that and those two seem
like a really awesome pair like just
watch those two work would be really
cool but like what they started oh yeah
they're having a blast now and now and
when they started that stream just the
way their whole in this book both you
guys said is that they started it is
just like okay it's like they're free
they took off all the shackles and
everything and they're just like all
right what's up and it was just like the
coolest I've seen them be to start any
of their streams ever and just
everything they said after that like for
me like big stuff has been like armor
2.0 them saying the MMO more like those
type of things like what free like those
were just like music to my ear so for
anything they talked about in the fall
like what are one or two big things that
you're really looking forward to I know
like the PDP like foundational shift is
obviously one was there anything much
you've seen so far that you're kind of
pumped about yeah well that's just like
that's probably my personal number one
right so we won't even like recognize
that because yeah I as you saw like
intellect disciplines
this one's strengths coming back so that
tells me they're probably gonna do
something about super mods and certain
while either just discontinue them or
whatnot but I think building the
character around how you want like
discipline strength which was so good
and then capping that it is a good way
for an overall player feel and then of
course you know having any armor that
you want to have the purchase that you
want on it right trans ma baby transmog
is huge and just the way you could like
I still want to understand armor 2.0
because they're like picking perks and
you have like eight or max of like ten
energy that you can apply towards said
perks like that
the stuff I want to hear about and
they're just they're gonna be
tight-lipped until they're ready but man
I can't wait to hear about that stuff
for me like it's such a small thing but
it's a big thing because every single
like in this game right now if you run
it enhance perks I mean aside from the
new iron Baron that just came out like
it was always your running raid gear or
you're running a dreaming city gear back
in destiny one to be high enough light
everyone was running around with the
vault of glass gear right for every nice
needs to come back I was forever 29 my
buddy was 30 so fast and I got screwed
for a while
and hopefully one day they do an apply
all shader that just consumes five of
them thank you and you're all right yeah
and your entire guardian is in that
shader yeah full preview and apply all
and then like weapons and armor like
just used once your weapons BAM those
could be severed yeah apply old armor
would be so nice those little things
like that's the type of stuff we're
seeing with like the universal ornaments
in ever verse the changes for bright
dust and like the way those purchases
are gonna work and stuff like all these
things everybody's like oh we don't know
if Activision soon as that they'd get
done with Activision they're like okay
BAM change this change this change this
like we're seeing a lot kriti quick
that's kind of surprisingly it's like
Lisa V sorry go ahead they've had cross
they ready for like a year yeah they
wanted to do it for the longest yeah I'm
sorry no no you're good and that's those
types of things it's like we're finally
giving a little more and even in the
button when they're doing the stream is
like yeah and all these things because
of well reasons in big giant quotes and
stuff like that yeah I'm sorry gotta
clear my throat that's that I got that
sore throat but those types of things
yeah it's like no one everybody was
always like well Bungie is doing some
things and we we know Bungie made some
calls like I still wonder when D to
launch what the whole two primaries was
this like Activision but like no one
knows those type of decisions like those
are questionable but when it comes to
stuff like ever or something and the
changes you see them make so quickly
have been quite telling of the things
they do get control over which have been
nice to see so no I just want to walk
around like everybody a bunch and they
shake their hand and be like man it it's
like it's been an amazing five years and
it sounds like we're just getting
started
yeah exactly mm-hmm yeah so well that's
a whole lot of rambling about just a
whole bunch of stuff just to get our
podcast started but that's how we do it
yeah I know you are totally fine our
podcast was called flashpoint before and
then we did a little name searching and
actually found we weren't the only one
so he switched it over to this figured
out we still weren't the only one but
talked to arrow scary lying over there
yeah he actually retweeted this thing
too because he actually had done kind of
a last word chat discussion thing and
but he hadn't done in a while so he let
him take up the mantle and then also
shout out to what is it lawrence
O'Donnell on MSNBC who has the exact
same name so we're like okay we can't
win but we stuck with this but it was
called flashpoint before but we usually
would joke that it was called long point
long point because it was never a flash
in the pan it was always like we would
be a joke
no you're always long-winded so that's
when you're like if you get off on it
like no you're in a great spot so well
yeah so this week obviously a couple big
things happened we had a heroic
menagerie lunch so that is one of the
biggest ones have you jumped in there
and checked it out and kind of kicked
its butt yet or have you been in there
much so we did one run and it was after
the raid we're like dude let's just
let's try menagerie and like we had zero
team comp I was the only well all right
mm-hmm
and we wasn't there and we got to the
final boss and we end up wiping but like
okay we'll just try it again another day
which would be today oh okay
and like between my friends and I like
that's always the thing right like well
when we're talking about five or six man
and something obviously like a full raid
team right we're like okay well we need
to have this swarm of the Raven and you
need to have this and then it all comes
down to this like well below it will be
just fine right like that's always the
answer with everything that we do just
go for it for it if glad can stole it
will be fine and he's almost done and
he's got into the final boss he's almost
figuring it out and that guy's amazing I
was getting watch glass oh yeah
he's crazy oh yeah mm-hmm no excuses
[Laughter]
really fun experience menagerie I mean
of course I didn't get to complete it
but there's a chance for the the burden
catalyst and then the master weapon so
absolutely so what do you think of okay
first I want to touch on like the
rewards for heroic basically we're
seeing I guess you get a chance to get a
curated piece of armor it seems like I
don't know if it'll be a curated a role
but it's like a full mast or a piece of
armor to get it that way and then I
think people are still kind of testing
to see if they get a curated role or a
guaranteed and then you have the chance
of the swords for as difficult as
menagerie can be or potentially could be
for some do you think adding a couple
things and maybe like one curated is
worth it for some or how do you feel
because now it's like you're almost
talking about a full match made rate if
you're taking six people in there it's
not the full length but it is definitely
putting in some work in some of the like
modifiers this week or black out and
iron and people are like please don't
put me in a riposte like stuff like that
how do you think it feels for what we're
getting out of it do you think the
rewards justify the difficulty I guess
is the best way to say it I'd have to
complete it Morgan but it's kind of how
to say Q like currently with the the
chest glitch which I mean it's
unfortunate it's getting patched right
that's topic 2 yeah we're getting there
like you know that's right it's like
well if like it it kind of feels like it
should be a little bit more maybe throw
in some regular armor mods in there or
something or maybe just because that
whole entire loophole like dust Rock air
until like it's all in there maybe throw
one of those weapons there on top right
mm-hmm
no be cool a little bit more or a better
chance because we all know like you can
get a weapon all you want but if it
doesn have the right perks it's done
yeah a lot of them go trash and you
could look out into a nice curated role
but other than that maybe a little bit
more for how much time it's going to
take because it take 2530 minutes
probably mm-hmm and if you wipe a couple
times and get halfway through it's like
good hour and a half or it's like yeah
it's a raid team that takes an hour
right it's
yeah that's all right so that's one of
the big topics that happened obviously
is heroic measure dropped we know a
couple swords have been dropped out
there and those seemed kind of cool and
swords actually seemed pretty viable in
the raid now for certain pieces but the
big thing is the chess glitch they call
it we a lot of people call it a glitch
we all figured it was a glitch now it's
been confirmed to actually be a glitch
and we're gonna get it patched on the
9th so I guess first off for both of you
I want to ask do you guys think that
like some people could hit it like 3 4
or 5 6 7 times and get pulls but then
you're still talking about orangy where
do you think like Bungie are they doing
the right thing do you think it should
just be one pole is there a middle
ground what do you guys feel and I'll
drop it to you first cool guy just to
see what do you feel about this whole
glitch where do you think it should be
do you think they're doing the right
thing leave it up to the community to
find something like that right like a
fan because you're so accustomed now to
going in especially if you have your
chalice up like even hit some of the
chest six times and then you'll double
up on so come with like 9 weapons which
is comical when you really think about
it but just getting one weapon and then
with the perk of possibility of two and
then we've all seen the rolls right you
get him say you get an Austria that's
full maxed ability was in a moment and I
don't know maybe it's not well that's 15
20 minutes that we they make like three
two or three mm-hmm possible pulls with
it I think would be just about right
like I think for the time he said with
the content two or three sounds just
about right I could see that like that's
one thing I think I've heard in a couple
places but what about you Cognito yeah I
mean it's tough because you know I I'm
late again I was at the e3 so I'm not
playing casual I finally playing though
I finally played when either so first
off top love it I do love it I mean I
think the thing that attracts me right
now is
the six-man cooperative aspect you know
batch made its it's literally like you
know mini raid light you know saying I
love that aspect there's some light
mechanics and I actually think it's
something they need to continue to do
going forward because it will encourage
people to do raids I feel when you have
more lighter mechanics like how this has
you know it's just so much fun you know
we beat the bosses that I saw people
doing the treasure chest glitch I'm like
what's going on back and forth
Oh Castile but um you know reference to
your question you know I struggle with
listen that's new players we gonna find
stuff you know so I get it but I think
it obviously wasn't intended that way
and then obviously once we start getting
our God rows and we start blazing
through I'm worried that you know it
will shorten this content you know and
this is part of that grind so you know I
hate to be the fun police but I think
they bill got a real it in you know that
I have disagree with a boy cg or this
gluon listen you got you got one run man
you got you gotta get you one run you
get your reward they didn't get out but
they I think they want you to keep
playing and I'm just worried that if we
keep grinding and we keep putting our
hand in the cookie jar so old many tiles
that you're gonna have everything and
then it's like okay we're gonna stop
playing again
I personally don't yeah I was like for
me it's kind of like I'm somewhere in
the middle ground I think it would be
nice to see them do a way to balance
like rewarding higher level play so if
there's a way for you to get through
like if you just kind of you're like
okay we get like seven percent okay we
and you if you fail the encounters but
get to the boss maybe that's one pull
but maybe say your group is like you're
really fast but you hit two perfectly
you finish up that third you hit your
bar and then you go to the boss you
might get one or two extra pulls for
doing it well especially as we get
higher level and things like that it
will get easier to do those types of
things and then if the skill actually
gives you some benefit of reward that
would be some way and somewhere in that
middle ground is what I would kind of
like to see is two to three or doing an
encounter well if you finish one
completely getting something extra
because if you go through and you spend
thirty
and it's like I mean a lot of the roles
that we get are questionable anyway if
you go run strikes or a whole bunch of
stuff is usually just crap anyway that
we get so if we get a chance at least
steer one or two these are roles that we
get whether it's a piece of armor and
it's only like two or three you still
gotta go spend some time in there and
then taking that to the next level when
you get to heroic like that one needs to
have something whether it's like
specifically a chance at like extra mods
or somebody even set it in chat like
talking about the sniper like actually
having the mod separate or something
would be a really cool way to do that
but I just like to see and I think
that's one thing a lot of even the the
raid itself people have been just saying
it's like yeah you can get armor that
has some enhanced perks but the weapons
are you know there's not much really
coming from the raid right now so and I
think it's just they've got to for the
fall especially I'd like to see like all
these concepts are cool the six-person
matchmaking like then you have the
heroic version and the difficulties and
stuff I want the rewards and that's
where again the more MMO piece I want
the rewards to start being more worth it
as opposed to just one more roll jockey
I can meet you to middle tier I could
meet you in a minute name it is it maybe
like I said is I also have like a
halfway point where you rewarded
automatic you know with a driver and
then the full completion or like you
said with the based on how well the
group I think yeah like another poll
there would give you like progress be
like hey you made it halfway through you
hit that middle bar
okay cool after this encounter you got a
pull on a chest like on your path in
between okay you go finish up the boss
you know if you did it well if you did
the challenge or something you may get
one or two extra like stuff like that
that they used to do would be nice just
to give you a little more a little more
incentive to push otherwise you can just
like go over in to matchmake
okay cool we finished through I got my
one pull like there won't but people
won't care as much and there won't be
incentive to actually like excel
I feel like cool guy you still there
you're me okay no are you cutting again
you doing like the cutting in and out oh
I wonder why it does that I'm sorry no
no no you're good sometimes I wonder if
like discord for like volume thresholds
and stuff like that I've got to keep
mine fairly close to so but no that's
like one of the biggest questions is I
think right now what this is gonna do to
season of opulence cuz everybody started
and like opulence was like on high rate
contest Menagerie came out the loot
grinds been good they've added a couple
bosses heroic got the catalyst and stuff
like that but now we're kind of at the
point of we're gonna get lumina next
week which we don't know much about by
the way they have a bit of a tease in
there as to what is to come how they
describe it basically yeah where's the
wording on that in the 12 I'm actually
looking for it yeah they use some
verbiage basically saying Guardians
wielding this weapon to support each
other in combat so it's kind of that's
the only kind of clue live given
obviously besides go to the easy look
for it but uh I'm getting I'm getting us
support five based on that so let's see
I mean the design looks cool
I mean I'm dying to know yes it's
another damn hand cannon but I am very
curious about that one she does the year
of hand cannons cannon sensor here I
think we're gonna have all the hand
cannons like next year no more hand
cannons but I enjoy them too just like
anybody but there's a point for like
exotics like when's the lessons on ik
pulse yeah yeah we outbreak that was it
that was not new but it was a technical
it's not like Paul's Church um what
about an exotic side our man come on no
I'm just kidding Wow so that's actually
question the last one and then we can
just move on a little bit yeah give me
my hot moon and I'll be happy miss
hawkmoon if you are an Xbox now go ahead
I'm not gonna say a quick question for
both of you oh is that what you first
what exotic
you want to return that if you had to
rank you know what's the what exotic is
not here from d1 that you really want
back yes that's not gonna break the game
is a giant caveat you build oh forgot
about break the game just what you want
what do you want for ones that I had
like a special place for in certain
moments like I was never that good with
it but I always loved hawkmoon when I
got to enjoy it and then also bad juju I
have a special place for though like bad
juju the ornaments on it always look so
cool is a quick three burst and I cannot
tell you how many like prison of elders
guides and things that I did when you
need super to come back that that was
like that was my baby a lot of the time
when I was rude you of city of my flow
oh my god yeah bad juju bad you for a
weapon bad juju was really it was one of
the ones that I really miss having I
think because what it was able to do CG
what about you man oh man dude I have so
many I can go on like goes here oh man
it's like like like non game-breaking
like the first one that comes to mind is
bully in Gemini mmm
always felt like now that I know what I
know now that bully in Gemini was made
for destiny too because back if we
remember that it had two perks that had
one way or another you get a head shot
yeah if you get a head shot you get more
mobility if you get a body shot you have
more armor so like that didn't really
work in Destiny one right it does work
because I mean maybe it'll max out your
stat right so I think bullying Jeb and I
would be good something like that while
Locke would be really good oh like it
goes like Oh what was it the eye of the
storm it was a solar pace it was
overflow this this weapon is called
following rate of fire and stability
while the wielder super is charged like
and it was for solar ones who were
saving it and they actually that was a
good like they had class specific
exotics they haven't done that in
destiny too at all mmm that was the best
one I think but still
to breath I'd be good and I'm also
really good are really fine with them
reimagining them like Crimson right
mm-hmm Bret turning a crimson auras
Allah super cell with with some sort of
reimagine ation maybe turning like the
billion Gemini into a sidearm yeah
almost like a like a red the Crimson
kind of a deal yeah I like you guys
remember hereafter when he got a head
shot
it's since a blinding grenade to the
area around it like I thought that was
so cool like even a pvp like what about
you who asked the question we've gotta
get to your answer it's like it's like
seasickness Obama you stole my bad juju
that was baby I really like this was
strong
most of mines came back to be on it's
like Lord of wolves now it's back in
crazy form
sleep sleep o his baby you know saying
out that was the giant um yeah you know
what I don't want vex mythoclast only
because I never got a chance to
experience it in d1 when it was at its
height at its pinnacle so I really want
to know what that feeling is and I would
like to see um you know that kind of
brought back and what was the UM there
was a what was that one that never came
back it was a fusion that uh plugs in OH
landed Plan C plan C was dope but no it
was another fusion I could infinity
pocket infinity there we go
yep always had so much potential to and
it never never doesn't like I defy day I
will say there's one I'm looking through
like the list of everything out there
right now I can only imagine what
patience in time would break in destiny
to right now cuz that's when you let go
ATS you Cohen is that would be
interesting so that's like there are
some in there but I'm also we've got so
many d1 exotics in d2
at this point like though they gotta
outweigh the D if they bring anything I
want like you know it's got to be like
10 to 2 max like I want a lot more new
ones than old ones at this point because
we've had a lot of old stuff come back
like half of our armours basically only
one so honorable mentions i lo though
oh no it's so good every arc burns all
the supersoul yeah for just all the all
the things so that was like my then the
lord auto-rifle my hung jury - well yeah
so lumina coming not entirely sure you
get like two days before you actually
you said you're out there cool guy
you're out there on the second so you
won't even get to really start that
quest will you I know I know
like don't remind me I was like where's
my stadia puck so I can play on this TV
and get progress though so that was
interesting like when you said Stata you
think stadia is gonna go like you think
stadia is gonna be big so just out of
curiosity offshoot on tech since we both
are giant nerds as well what makes you
think that about stadia just out of
curiosity because I got done loving up X
cloud so like they currently said that
stadia won't be able to play with PC
which I mean everyone kind of expected
you would think right so I would hope
that cross play in the future is gonna
be happening but take the new consoles
right so the new consoles are gonna work
as a as a server so you can log into
your xbox from not at your Xbox
essentially maybe your away or maybe
like they were saying like even though
I'm never talking with a new Xbox maybe
you're at Thanksgiving right and
deserves coming on and he sell on the
Gjallarhorn you just kind of log him
right there oh yeah to me and they
always talk about the future that is the
future of gaming things like that so
stadia is the first part and I will be
trying it and testing it
I'll be using a controller because the
last mouse and keyboard game I played
was like missed or Oregon Trail mob he
sees me with this yeah and I'm over
there with my actual mouse and keyboard
so yeah all right that's all right both
you'll probably kick my butt anyway so
it's you good man you don't give you
some no because um you know just as a
tech we're all we all geeks here we all
love tech you know saying yeah excited
about this stuff so for me you know
being at e3 you know getting a chance to
test X cloud you know and I can say
literally it was literally an elite blow
with a bass and you know a galaxy s 10
and I was just thinking looking all the
possibilities like I said you're not
home and stadia still represents
something because the browser aspect you
know again you travel remotely you know
you can just login essentially just have
a controller and still be able to play
so if you don't want to lug a console
around you know and you got semi-decent
you know internet and according to them
you know they're gonna put your plate
you get you up to resolution zone
hey they're saying for okay I got to see
I'll take 1080p good
I'll take 1080p 60 and think about it so
many people who you know like you said
see like your current rig right now is
not you know where you want it to be
ideally for a you know destiny PC spec
so imagine of someone who doesn't have a
rig who is working you know remotely or
just in that in their own house and say
hey I want to play some destiny could
just jump in right quick and I'm just
thinking of things to continue the grind
when I'm not home like that excite them
yes absolutely the future like that's
their vision right to play anywhere
destiny anywhere so like it's all huge
for the game see my curiosity is gonna
be sorry the the player base on stadia
cuz as you guys are all saying it's like
hey I am in a hotel hey I am out for
Thanksgiving it's like dis de Deus
population biggest on the holidays and
then when you're back home nobody's on
it like cuz like if I can take the puck
in the controller with me it's cool
visit my wife family and we're up there
for a few days I don't have to look my
computer if I want to do a couple things
can't make videos without it but that's
a different issue but just right yeah
theoretically if stadia was out right in
the hotel internet is fairly decent yeah
hold on hey cool guide psycho let me
plug this into my like HDTV in my room
here got my controller hope the
connection doesn't suck let's go I got
my Kindle so it's got I mean it's really
cool like we're at a point in time now
like I know you got to go to an e3 that
was like a start because ether like
stadia did their little announcement
before with destiny and then you got to
see you explode like this is kind of
like the very beginning of like the next
phase of a lot of stuff like X cloud the
remote play and all those things are all
coming in different ways and this is
like the first piece and Bungie is like
yes let's do that and I think it's
really cool that we actually get to see
them at the right time that they're free
that they can talk about it the way they
want to because if they were like behind
activation they'd be like they would be
able to like say they wouldn't be able
to say half the stuff that they want to
now they're just like play anywhere no
exclusives and all that stuff and
they're just gonna be like we want to do
cross play but we got crossed just the
fact that they've said the words cross
play in interviews the fact that it's a
want is awesome because you know they
want to it's just the infrastructure
whether they wait for the new consoles
like what is it gonna take to get there
is it a d3 and stuff like that so took
12 hours for the damn cross a foundation
of what it would take for you know cross
play completely I should have a fairly
healthy player base because they made
that deal like you get you know if you
sign up early you get all of destiny
forsaken with stadia for free right
mm-hmm yeah that's the one thing that's
really gonna help it to new light yeah
mm-hmm
new light that's the thing actually like
new light is gonna be huge for the
player but just everywhere then I will
freeze Noto berries into comp yes let's
go I mean cool guys KD is already pretty
high but as soon as it's like alright
it's September 18th man Mike just Katie
is just climbing
don't know why I can only imagine how
many people you're gonna be making feel
real bad about trying to play against
you so but hey at that point you know
like September 14 15 16 17 if you get
more of those like improve your KD
videos up you're gonna be just exploding
sir it's something to think about man
I've thought about it trying to try to
get a game plan going into it you know
I've been like okay so you're new to
destiny like I know I've got to make
like a couple of those like you're new
to destiny series like what to think
about don't be an idiot in public events
please don't shoot this guy like there's
there's some stuff like the average
person who has no clue what's going on
could probably used to see that was
dirty came from the moon things like you
you don't you don't shame the the new
guy like that's that's been me for the
longest time is yeah like I've been
trying to I've been making content for
solo players because that's like play
for a long time some some of my friends
would be around or wooden for a little
while but it's like it was the point was
like I wanted to challenge myself to see
if I could solo at nightfall and
especially with the extinguish it sucked
like there were many a deaths and Mineo
reduce but then it finally got to that
point it was like okay I can do this now
let me see if I can make it to where I
could help other people do it and that
was the goal for a while and then it's
the live commentary and stuff like that
I can't tell you how many times I've
repeated the phrases that I've said in
my recordings like take 10 and like
saying all this stuff over and over but
it's like when it finally does come
together well people do appreciate it
that's the same thing for you cool it's
like I can tell thee the time you put
into yours it's a very very obvious and
just hats off to what you do as well
because yours is the detail the time
it's like and that's one of those like
because honestly watching yours not
trying to steal yours but just the way
you do your videos is making me like I
wonder if I truly did just spend like
three or four days with a gun or a piece
of armour and just like okay this is my
thoughts on it or like this is how you
can use it and that's the way you spend
days with something it's not just like
hey I got it here's a couple here's my
first play game play cool it go you're
like no I want to know the ins and outs
the workings and those types of things
and that's those are the ones I think
that
people feel like hey you know videos
can't be like two minutes you're like oh
or I can do a 15 minute video about
demolitionist that turns into a video
about a perk and then all of a sudden
you're like hey I have a whole different
video I didn't expect to have so yeah so
I mean what's so cool about here's my
personal deal ban like everyone has been
so in my experience very supportive man
like I talked to Rick a kiss and by fan
Mesa Sean and like blew all of this yeah
yeah and they and they helped me write
and I helped them when I can like
everyone is pulling for each other and
what's so cool about the Destiny content
creation community is like there's
literally a place for everyone whether
it be you know a funny video or like an
on the surface like I'm gonna show you
the gun video or like a hot take video
like it's all there I'm like well you
know like I said I've tried doing kind
of an on the surface video when I get
something like okay this is it I'm
showing it to you guys this is what it
does but like get it and go into like
Khepri sting is a good example man like
everybody hates Khepri sting like well
let's look at Khepri sting so I made
like a 14 minute video on it you know
trying to uh now it's how to use it how
to find success with it things like that
that's just that's just I love doing it
I love getting into weapons like I said
I'm shot every weapon in the game
it just it's my jam right mm-hmm
it's more so for me and for them I guess
good stuff oh oh yeah tell me about hush
I haven't I haven't got that yet I've
been slowly working on it like it it's
an extremely skillful weapon and but I
was messing with it dude like again I'm
on console like it hits shots at over
120 meters like it's hitting full damage
the accuracy on its like it it's it's
essentially over 100 because the opening
shot like the hitbox is like you could
aim at their chest it's a head shot it's
an amazing Bose like what I what I'm
gonna talk about in this review is like
even if you don't get the main perk
going and the main perk is lethal like
it's still like one of the best pose in
the game
period mmm nan Xia like that you have to
hit fire it right and that's tough on
console it's like I'm kind of working
through it so I get thirty four and a
half meters your aim assess just
completely stops like on console and I'm
really excited to kind of show my
findings with it like it's 34 to half
meters which is coincidentally the same
exact effective range of an Austria okay
uh uh so but when you get that perk
going you have a lot of fun it's like
honestly for me it's one of the most fun
I've had in Destiny a long time do you
like it's such a fun weapon and a hold
its own in PvE as well like I did the
entire crowd to start a raid with it
like it's fine really
damn guys I did since that cool guy
laughs I'm like I'm not man he's over
here breaking it down showing how
effective it is and I'm like alright
damn it I gotta go just put it through
the paces cuz cuz cool guy said I
laughed at that weapon when it was
announced like I'll just like uh what is
this why am I gonna hit by with it we go
practically in constable specifically
right it's like everything matters like
enhanced bow targeting and bow targeting
like that helps the Amos it's like you
need all that for this thing to work
well and the PC guys from like 40 50
meters can just hit people in the head
from hipfire like you can't do that on
console like you have too many factors
you have thumbs right it's hard to do
you have to give them lately different
than a PC player so like I'm excited to
get into that but it's a very high skill
gap weapon dude and when you're when
you're jamming with it like your rocket
and shaking like I love it
but you put that out so I guess the
other question since we're talking about
pinnacles at this point what are your
thoughts on now the path to get revoke
her and also like revoke like Rooker
itself like the perk just like I don't
know the best way to say it is not
rewarding skilled play kind of as you
said like hush is a skilled weapon and
somebody who actually puts the time in
as good with a bow is good with it Navy
got revoke her as a sniper and it's not
bad but it's like you're rewarding
misses more than you are reported
rewarding like skilled shots with a
sniper which is something
everybody wanted something to be good so
what do you think about that I'm still
working on it but I know all about and
I've seen it you're still with revoke
her in that entire quest line that's the
best thing that they could have done for
comp yes I will agree with the quest
line yeah yeah because it gets players
in there they're always getting you know
if they win a game they're always
getting progress like that's the best
thing that they could have done they
should have done that the entire time
mmm it helps for more healthy player
population right right okay it has the
lowest zoom in the game it's tied with
Twilight oath and oh there's one more
guard one longshadow maybe with a
certain scope but it's got a very low
scope it's high impact it's got the
original og ambush scope which is like
my favorite like more the short games I
love it investing one nice but I'm okay
with the perk because I think the
pinnacle weapons like dude Lunas how is
game breaking not forgotten his game
breaking and it was I mean it went on
for way too long though that's just my
personal opinion right like it was
supposed to write oh my god
everywhere and it's funny now because
people are still using them but you can
compete with them like you can outshoot
them a lot easier now before it was just
like you get deleted you couldn't do
anything about it like if you're using
an AR ASA spades you're done on you know
it's supposed to get players in the
playlist and I'm telling you right now
like Lucas how it kept players out of
comp know the weapon the weapons being
used against them they couldn't do
anything about it
so with revoke er I'm okay cuz all it is
is a guaranteed Mulligan right it's
almost like a reverse icebreaker right
well I mean I don't have a hundred
percent accuracy right oh definitely not
me
you're gonna miss shots right so I mean
so that tells you with that weapon if
you're gonna miss miss high right but
obviously somebody's low I don't ever
shame and you shouldn't either for body
and somebody with a sniper rifle right
I'm okay because it's not game breaking
but it is pinnacle and the fact that if
you're missing shots you shouldn't miss
some high and you're gonna have a lot of
ammo but that being said though I think
beloved's a lot better sniper rifle love
it yeah
aim assist is off the charts for console
it has the right part
um snapshot quick draw or with box
breathing it's one of three very special
weapons in the game that can down a
super office fun with being Satara gays
is an Auggie's burden and now beloved
it's like that's a special thing and
then of course no distractions that's a
whole nother story all right
sets you can put together I think is
gonna be a better overall experience
that haven't revoke er got you enough
yeah I mean in the night aspect it's
kind of a shame yeah because you just
you're like oh here's this other PvE
activity that like just puts that other
one you know kind of puts it down a peg
reduce so now it is kinetic but I'm fine
with my bite of the Fox with explosive
rounds like is it aggressive framin like
I think it doesn't yeah those ones I get
killed by the most that yeah I did Fox
the other one I'm apparently probably
doing everything completely wrong with
what I'm playing with lately so I have a
persuader wrong with that but it's got
the short zoom scope so it's got the 50
Val telescopic but it's got snap shot
sites moving target and a third target
adjuster on there having some fun with
that one actually like just the
snappiness of that scope it's like the
fastest one I've ever seen at least and
I'm sure there are old ones like it but
just the in and out of that zoom is so
so quick I've really enjoyed it and that
just shows my ignorance when it comes to
a lot of sniper stuff but I have been
having fun with that one but I've got my
50 precision kills and they've got two
out of three hundred for the kills and
then I gotta go work my comp work but I
kind of want to work on at the lowest
glory level possible see if I can get a
little more progress towards mountaintop
because that's one that eludes me and
man that quest sucks
God mountaintop is brutal yes rough man
it is rough is no doubt about it yeah it
has been interesting well like a lot of
the pinnacle at like mountaintop now
used in a lot of raids recluse is used
in a lot of PvE activities now that wild
it's like so those pinnacles are being
pulled over and stuff it even for a
legendary hand cannon like not forgotten
in Lunas as well still pretty solid when
it was better again PB as well so you
can a wish they might had to give my boy
regex a little of Frederick's Claymore
come on man
eating the sound with it like I mean
desperado was cool and all but it's just
like you know it's just not in the meta
you know that that that style of pulse
and I just I think it does need a little
something especially you know it's part
it's up there's a critical weapon is a
semi grind for it's not crazy it's just
now longevity you know kind of sticking
with it but um I would like for them to
do because it seems like every other one
now is kind of finding every other
pinnacle weapons kind of finding its its
place and it's something except that one
in my in my opinion well I've been using
my go figure for so long so if another
pulse rifle is good I'm sure I'd find
out my go figure has like forty thousand
kills on it or something
there you go well it's an outlaw rampage
appended magazine even that great but
it's got the devil's it's a long zoom
scope I got a range master work on it
with counterbalance I just like I just
laser people from across that I love
that gun in PvP like mmm-hmm but give me
a medium range of screwed I gotta I
gotta play a little farther with that
one but I do love when I get zapped I'm
all just all the noise nieghbors with
that gun which is what I love doing
so Oh but yeah so we had her open every
chest glitch now which is gonna I know
it had to happen I know it's gonna have
to happen just kind of a shame we'd like
to see some balance out of it and then
we have finally they're announcing a
date for the grimoire anthology - did
either of you guys get the first book
the anthology one I have it's so good
it's so nice like the second one coming
- so we've got and I think they
literally made this emote for like byph
and Milan games and a couple of them
[Music]
just like let me open my book and then
if you buy the emote you did to get a
discount on the lore anthology so
that'll be pretty cool so yeah that
one's just a small announcement but
definitely one that I can see those two
just like that's like part of them now
the lore books and stuff so I've got a
little bit about the Bungie foundation
so of course if you guys didn't see
Guardian carnival where we're all going
bungee to the 400 K loop Oh with the 9 /
900,000 on his block was just so crazy
he's gonna be a guardian con as well
silly shake a shake his hand for what he
did first st. Jude it's almost a million
in four and a half hours but they're
trying to raise a little bit more so
they've still got their goal for through
the bungee Foundation they're trying to
do iPads for Kids program that they're
doing so between now and July 14th
they're trying to raise 77 thousand
dollars to get as that donation towards
that program and again if you do want to
contribute 50 bucks you will get your
system of peace it's another heart
emblem so that's one of those things I
think is I know they do it I don't know
we follow the bungee blocks a lot but I
don't see a lot and I'm not saying other
developers don't right but I was like I
don't see as many developers do like
this much for their community I guess
and and it may be a piece of just where
I'm not as close with developers and I'm
sure they do but just like I got a shout
out to Bungie and like just just all the
work they like so much of the store they
don't even keep like so much of the
proceeds go to just like a good cause
all the time I forget to like the
details on that but I don't know that's
one of the have you guys ever seen any
other dad was like do that type I think
there's so many things that Bungie does
that like are understated that probably
keep us fanboys attached to them even
more they're very special man what's
cool about Bungie is like you know I'm
Rick was new sea-doo I was so upset when
they left dude because like I've been
following their careers for forever it
seems like forever I would follow those
guys and I don't know what happened
maybe they just I mean whatever it
that's between them but you know I used
to really enjoy and that's another thing
Bungie did man I I love them actually
when they used to go and take a team
like they would take the sound team and
a by dock and like they would go out and
like the desert and get weird noises and
like okay this is how we made the Zen
meteor sound like I think that that's so
cool and no one really does that we look
at blogs like like apex and anthem it's
a general from Bioware from I mean every
now and then they'll bring in a dev but
they'll say hey you know developer here
they don't really specify what they do
Bungie is very in touch with their
community
and they really value their deaths and
you can see the passion when you talk
into by Doc's dude like when they're
talking about their weapons and their
work like they're so passionate about it
man and that's why I'm kind of happy
that they're on their own ship because
it's like a party now like you have a
party right now yeah I feel the walls
are coming down and I think you've
nailed it I mean to your question II
look and I've been gaming a long time
you know and just my just my experience
I know yes desti is one of my favorite
games ever
but in my experience I've never seen a
development team I've never seen that
level of intimacy with the community and
their level of interaction and you know
for them to be going to Guardian con and
things like that I mean got a chance you
know they did a few times and it's just
you feel it you feel you feel the energy
and I that's one thing when you see like
the st. Jude stuff and the Bungie
foundation stuff you know I don't see it
I don't see everybody god I'll see
others yeah here's patch notes for the
week you know and you know they may have
you know a dev once in a while but like
like CG said like watch Avatar watch a
ride-along
alright what's animals talk about
anything exactly the door protect him at
all costs you just see that passion man
you know even you know people shouts a
couple of law people that that left
recently but you know just even talking
about little things and nuances into why
decisions were made I love that stuff
and and it's very rare in gaming you
know in my opinion that you get this
level of intimacy with the dev yeah the
vibe because those are always really
cool when they take the second when they
showed the guy talking about the
artifacts he's like man this last year
it's almost gonna be like exotic perks
they're gonna be like really really
powerful like he's pumped about his
thing that he's working on it's like
he's like I am legit like out of my
chair like excited for you guys to get
your hands on this it's like when for
shake and drop and they would debut in
the subclass trees and they were talking
about the new super Sandow
it was I was pumped yeah cannot wait and
then you've got the finishing moves
coming up that I forgot about that
that's still I've died I think I fell
out of my chair almost when I was lat I
was literally laughing out loud I'm like
this is Mortal Kombat we have finished
it punching punching ogres and they're
back flipping off I like a ragdoll
effect - on the augers it's like the
greatest thing ever oh my god like that
is that is one of those things I'm like
how do you for one that's one of those
things that proves the community has no
idea what they need bungy won't like
figure it out sometimes because we would
know what he would have ever thought of
that and all of a sudden like I'm gonna
go punch an ogre in the face and he's
gonna go flying off the moon like what
crazy
that type of stuff looks so much fun she
should be back on the gold just so you
can finish looks like she actually looks
like she's in there she's a very unique
looking wizard and she is one of those
like you see crota you see phogoth I'm I
would bet money of the omnigul or an
omnigul phantasm or whatever it is
called she's in there
I would probably bet cuz I stared at her
damn face too much in what is it an
uppercut for me dude oh my god I can't
wait her scream still haunts my
nightmares when I that's right whoever
did this oh I was just saying that
scream is terrifying oh I was like when
Crowley's I mean what's gonna chrono
eros used to say her name
you know same went at the beginning of
the of the mission or strike away
give me hype like yeah more Legrand ona
yeah she's won that like I've seen her
on a couple podcasts like she always
seems really really cool I think she's
gonna be at Guardian contests and I
can't wait to meet her man I know yep
you know she's gonna be there so go look
up her Twitter make sure you know what
she looks like so shake her hand for
bringing yo like her and Kade are part
of my one of my favorite lines in all of
Destiny is get your rock off my map I
love that line from cabe and like and
just though
the those two are about as perfect for
like counter of each other as you could
possibly have and they're so good and we
lost one but it's been it's been a while
since but we're getting married so quick
quick question for Google got a lower
question so uh being that he just talked
about a faded friend you know we lost
our guy so uh is is this the aldryn
returned do we do we get him at the
table we get him at the tower
what do you think I sure hope so wit
like natto was talking about it in that
reveal foreshadow keep like I think it's
on the plate dude like I think it's on
the plate at some point mm-hmm it's
almost impossible maybe Kade can somehow
make a return okay seven kernel 2.0 like
oh man so that's most of all we got for
the 12 I know they've got some known
issues and stuff like that there's some
cool videos of the week definitely check
those out we have Guardian con us the
peace coming so if you guys are going to
Guardian con obviously all of us are
gonna be there but I've got a couple
general questions of always like to get
other opinions when we have you guys on
here so for you cool guy just kind of a
curiosity and a thought and this has
been kind of in flux as of lately for a
lot of people too so we've got shadow
keep we've got supposedly four other
seasons kind of first piece is do you
think for the next season pass and stuff
like that do you think it's gonna keep
to a 3-week cadent or three-month
cadence do you think they're gonna have
a little more spacing in there what do
you picture for like the next season
paths of content do you see it just like
truly calendar year do you think if they
need the freedom freedom they'll take it
like what do you expect for shadow keeps
like cadence of releases and just kind
of what to look for in the upcoming year
and then I'll get to the even bigger one
I think that this next pass is gonna be
strikingly similar to this one it's
gonna have a big expansion
use me like forsaken right shadow keep
and they're gonna add on to it and I
think that because it's all on their own
it's right there in the studio so I
think that's a perfect chance to gauge
what they can handle mm-hmm I think that
once they figure out what they can
handle that's the move to add more or
less but I think it's I think it's gonna
be good and what's cool like I said is
they're away they're very open now like
I said you can see you Luke Tagum you
know much people talk like because they
can now it seems right Capital are
reasons yeah think honestly if the
players want it they're gonna try it you
know some way shape or form they can't
guarantee it but they're at least look
into it so and be similar to this pass
after the after the first you know year
I guess but the following one I think
that there's gonna be some changes now
meeting more hopefully it could be about
the same but I think that they need to
judge has a studio what they can handle
that's fair
so then the other question is and this
is one that we've had a lot of talks
about this but it's also like we've had
some changes in like understanding well
as we get more knowledge about Bungie
and as they say like hey we were we put
the contest modifier and there we've
just had some devs kind of do a bit of a
crunch and instead of doing Lord of
wolves now we're gonna give our you know
dev some time to like be humans and not
put it through crunch and stuff like
that so the idea is if they keep on this
cadence or even as you said maybe
spacing more or less or whatever's in
the future where do you picture or do
you even want a destiny 3 that's kind of
it like I know it's - part of like do
you even want it do you want an
evolution of destiny - or there or is
there things that you think only a d3
can do so trying to get your breakdown
on that whole big giant question mark
the deado tried to ask and obviously get
get an answer to either I I personally
believe that there will be a destiny 3
and I only say that because the next
generation right this it was very held
back on consoles mhm
with loading times and like so imagine
the freedom that they're gonna have with
the current like Destiny's a huge game
always talking about patch
it's like well why does it take so long
to patch things like fortnight's just
one big map in their quote in beta right
it's still maybe maybe the real version
could have come out but maybe that means
that's they can push patches out like
it's no problem
right because but every time they do
that they have to pay to get these
patches to go along now they can hotfix
on their side but the actual patches to
fix stuff cost some money and they have
to do them all at once essentially like
they do big patches when the seasons
come out I have to think it's because
destiny is right now imagine with you
know appointed second loading screen go
from the moon to the Mars and then be at
60 frames like it it's it's almost like
that's the end goal and I think that
they want to get to an end goal for
destiny give me the final version they
might just call it destiny or maybe
destiny 3 and have it as they want it to
be and just an MMO kind of like World of
Warcraft right like that would be to me
the perfect like way we're gonna end it
and keep going right just a type of
mentality but I do hope and I believe
that there will be a test III that just
me though okay so it's like so you
wanted e3 so here's the other question
is win win do you see it falling in like
if it's like certain years because if
we're talking like we've got now content
with shadow keep him finish till a year
through basically August of 2020 roughly
obviously all guesses but where do you
picture d3 falling for their development
cycle and then also as you said with the
new consoles where do you think it fits
best
well I a lot of us follow at me because
I remember they had a hundred million
dollar mobile game deal right so I don't
even know what's going on with that it's
like there's development team working on
that and while they were when they had
Activision like they were making shadow
keep they were making the gambit stuff
like there's stuff that has a Destiny's
blueprint all over it like but out there
it's just kind of tough like do they
have teams working on destiny through
right now like no one knows right
there's no way to know so if they are
then I would expect it probably like in
three years
mmm interesting I'm gonna have their
ears okay 2022 ish 22 ish so you dig
they start off the next console
generation still remaining in Indy - I
do
ok thank interesting yeah we've had our
speculations of what were you were
saying were you thinking launch of
consoles or where were you at right
after right after um Indy threes right
after I think d3 is probably if I'm
gonna guess again no pride now this is
just me guessing
um consoles are gonna come in what 2020
I mean so far I figure for 2020 I'm
saying 2021 I think they might be ready
in the fall they stick with their
September cadence and um that's what I'm
going with cuz it'll be a full year of
them kind of adjusted to the new
consoles and they've kind of crossed
generation d1 before so again just
speculation you know I think they're
ready to go I know for a fact you know
um these guys are working on it Luke
Smith in a Noseworthy job even that'll
kind of hinted at it in the recent case
ago we're not ready to talk about it at
this time
you know marketing speak but it's being
worked on this there's no doubt about it
you know it's just a matter of the
timing in you know we'll see we'll see
what happens I know I've just thinking
about it
like everything you said I mean is think
about at that point next generation
would have settled in you know you got
those those beasts of sins and you know
the navvies and then you got you know
SSDs on consoles these are huge things
you know and then the ultimate vision of
cross play I still think that is where
they ultimately want to be and cross say
was gonna definitely rise the base up
from shadow keep on but once you're
talking about cross play now granted you
know PC and console in mantis separate
them you're a baby filter your
continuity board mouse lists and stuff
like how sweaty this may be a sweaty
button do you want to
engage in this sort of activity with oh
boy M&K floodgates
exactly exactly what oh yeah I mean it I
think that is the gold man and and and
once they do that Dusty's gonna be hard
to pee
cuz now you're talking cross state and
cross play man I don't know what a lot
of Luther shoes gonna be able to do with
that
that that is HUGE HUGE Yujin all the
word lanes is gonna get a lot of play
when it comes out you know right around
the same time mm-hmm why it's so smart
on Bundy's part to be like you know what
you buy this season pass if you want
this season
that way players can't come back like
Sandy ray comes out very smart on their
part yes yeah new light new light is
gonna be probably one of the biggest
things for I think PC because the
student population is ginormous there's
so many new play games on Steam but most
like your free games of a decent level
are so few and far between I mean you've
got dauntless that is you know like
Monster Hunter 0.8 like it's not quite
there and then you've got fortnight
that's free and you've got some other
but like bigger free multiplayer you put
destiny where they can go roam planets
play the camp plane play DBP gambit like
gambit Sparta Forsaken and Gambas just
gonna be part of this I don't know if
game if crimes gonna be there that'll be
kind of interesting but I mean just the
fact that they can go in and do all of
those things and then be like it's free
that alone will help the population it
randomly microtransactions and stuff
like that is gonna be just so busy it's
literally a free test drive and you know
after a while you know new Guardians
come in they start playing would you
stop playing with your friend so you
know what all right I plunked down on
forsaken now just you know after messing
around and seeing what you guys doing
I'm really liking that - he's in a good
place
i I think this is huge man this new
model this new light model it could they
they're not restricting as much as I
thought they would I thought they would
really be more restrictive it's not as
bad and like you know cooler I said like
hey if you don't like you know a certain
specific DLC or a part of the annual
pass like I asked if this one you
get the one you want like a la carte
like they it's kind of crazy mmm
yeah it'll be like just buying the black
army fortress was skipping out on campus
crime or something like that wish that's
great what a lot of people probably
would have done for that one but I like
me it's like I know cuz if you buy the
whole pack it's like 35 foreshadow
keeping 25 more and I'm like that's like
you know two and a half seasons that's
like that's easy purchase for me to
justify because I'll get them all but
somebody is just like hey I just get the
expansion shadow keeps a standalone cool
I can play like the next season of
opulence cuz that's the really cool one
and I don't know I think it's gonna be
kind of crazy so that's definitely
something to look forward to as well but
I'm trying to think of anything else
we've got this actually kind of went
fairly quickly we were talking about the
gunplay earlier right and it what's so
cool about this new model is like and
this is a free-to-play game and they're
pretty much saying we stand by our
product you play our game I think you're
gonna like it
mags rights once you get hooked in man
like you say once you get hooked in that
gun play and again playing with your
friends no restrictions no you know oh
this exotic is only here and you know
say all this map is only here but all
that stuff you know yeah just finally to
bear with it and I there's a lot there's
people on mind on Twitter who I know I
like not their destiny haters when that
announcement got made for shadow keep I
see the budgets cream sauce installing
destiny together it's gonna bring some
people back is definitely and like I
said I think there are each player
population is reflective of that right
now
that it went back up to a million
because people are excited you know and
shout out to all its he teacup Rizzo
he's going at his he said I don't think
it'll be fair to be as far as the cross
play I see your point I think the only
thing I'm saying as far as cross play
yes I think consoles definitely you know
I'm saying that you know PlayStation
Xbox that kind of thing
PCs either gonna be separate or
optionally a probably they may keep it
separate but um there's no no doubt my
mind that cross play will come in some
in some form you know by dieter yeah and
I think the I think I don't know if it's
for tonight or something basically have
the option of like if you're playing
cross play on mouse and keyboard or on
console and controller do you I think
you have the option to pair up with
people unlike PC or ass and keyboard
something like I don't know which game
specifically but that's a way to Modern
Warfare's doing that too it's it's just
strict input based like you play other
controllers and like so PC would
probably be with stadia yeah I
completely see that completely yep
so I mean that I don't know there's
there's so much to look forward to in
the fall and it's not that far away
we're talking and we're almost in July
now and then it's like literally just
July in August and then we were talking
cool guy last week so I know we
obviously play a butt ton of destiny
technical measurement by the way of
course but what are you looking forward
to any other games in the fall because
we all know September is absolutely
bananas when I listed it off last time
like is there anything that is gonna be
like straining on your time taken away
from destiny because September alone is
packed much less anything else going on
so what else he looking forward to or
what I'll see you actually playing cuz
just to get a little I play a lot of
destiny and when you spend four days
with hush there's not a lot of time for
anything else
so so like my wife and I Xbox is like it
we have a cool game except there it's
like there it's like this is mine so
like basically the content just shares
right it's like on my xbox I have anthem
I have red dead I have Kingdom Hearts
and a couple others never even touched
him yeah right they're installed ready
to go yeah I do see myself playing
Borderlands because I love near box mana
so well certain developers like I love
Treyarch I love Bethesda I love gearbox
I love Bungie right so I give those
games a chance and I will be playing
Borderlands 3 yeah the only game I play
right now is apex Legends and it's
perfect because and I know it's a
free-to-play games about a Royale I just
dropped it with a couple friends play a
couple games and then back on a destiny
it's the only one I really see and I'm
gonna play cyberpunk like cyberpunk like
a generational game do like from
think that people are saying boy you
have no idea CG mm oh god chair to see
that that bad boy behind the scenes did
you oh yeah yeah check up check the
video on our lost podcast YouTube
channel for all let me tell you right
now that I know it's the foundation we
still got some time but what they just
what they've shown so far is so
mind-blowing to me they man they got it
feels like they got one if you're a fan
of Mass Effect and you know just you
know impactful choices it as far as just
the world itself a living breathing
world it looks phenomenal I cannot wait
for cyberpunk so so excited about that
yeah that one's gonna be big my brother
will never shut up about what your three
in justified consider me but it's like
what they did for like a game with so
much Contin sensing story I mean he said
the combat could use like some love and
stuff like that and that'll be the
interesting thing is like they're going
first-person shooter on this right yeah
they got it they got to tighten up the
um what's the word the the impact of our
fill of the gunplay I feel that if I had
to nitpick that was the only thing I
just said you know at the end of the
session you're allowed to give feedback
and part of my feedback which is like
look everything else you need to listen
to me you guys got a great game I think
the only thing they need to work on is I
felt like the again because this is now
the bungee and me then the deputy am
your spoil did yeah well it's the poeple
guns need to pop a little bit more and
the reactions when people get shot like
I need to feel that I feel like they
were kind of they were kind of spongy
like a little bit like Division one II
like you know sometimes that yeah like I
need you know that that reaction if they
get that visceral nature in it it's this
no don't touching it so that you know
that's but I think a lot of other people
who got to chance to see it immediately
we got a chance to see behind closed
doors that um yeah that those are like
that was the only consensus yeah a
little negative that we can nitpick but
other than that I mean again game is
phenom 2 different ways you can attack a
same scenario
stealthy personality-wise you know tech
wise I mean it's like three games in one
like one scenario played out so many
ways in a Mass Effect way and a stealthy
kind of what you call a Saxons Greenway
and a watchdogs way just based on your
class and how you completely customize
is phenomenal I'm stoked if that one's
gonna be crazy so I know my brother will
be playing that I think that's one of
those like I have to step away from but
yeah it's like there's so many I'm like
you cool guy because I've like I got
partway through horizon then I went back
to destiny and then god of war was
probably the one that I actually stepped
away and I made it all the way through I
think I didn't kill one Valkyrie but I
basically finished the whole game and
that's one of the first times in a while
I have truly finished one like breath of
the wild I'm like I'm at some weird
early point in that game because I got
it but again it was always me coming
back to destiny and it's like it's an
issue so that was like even yesterday I
didn't get to do what I wanted to do
because I had work and then I had to run
up to work in the middle of my day so
it's like the 12 hours the destiny was
off when I was like hey I could knock
out a game like inside or I could like
reboot breath of the wilds I'm like
Destiny's back on I'm like guess what
I'm gonna go do so I kind of wanted to
ask you and I know it's kind of one
thing that I've seen quite a few people
like coordinator Jake I saw him put out
his post where he's like taking a break
from streaming and stuff like that
do you ever or I mean have you
experienced or at least can empathize
with some people talk about like burnout
or you see people kind of having the
work/life balance of doing YouTube for
you are there certain aspects that
you've seen other times you've thought
about taking a break are you kind of at
a at a good point where you have found a
good balance for it and then if you have
what's your trick no like for me it's
how I approach weapons look into weapons
do like I said I really enjoy getting
new roles mm-hmm I think they had to
offer and then you know I'll get another
role so that's why it doesn't get boring
for me right mm-hmm
PvP aspect I mean it's a different time
every single time you play it right if I
was one of those guys that went into a
six stack and you'd not forgotten dust
rock I would probably be really burnout
right
I'm using trained Eagle against those
guys you and your Bose man you're scary
but it blows that yeah train Eagle I
think is gonna get a trial time catalyst
and it's gonna be really good it needs
something it needs a little bit of
something yeah I see drawl it's too slow
but no so it's always refreshing for me
that and so like I feelin says because
my wife came back to play right so she's
top so it she's she's a casual destiny
player she loves a PvP but she really
enjoyed the menagerie so that to me I
was like well Bungie did a good job my
wife likes it that's a that's a fair bar
absolutely so and I mean with the
community man like I'm doing raids I'm
doing just this whole bunch there's
always something to do in destiny right
that's what's so great about destiny so
yeah gonna it and have a good time with
it so yeah sounds like you got a nice
balance REE not just like absolutely
burning out like do you have like a day
job and stuff and this is more on the
side or is this your full-time gig oh I
am a I'm a rated radiologic technologist
and I did that for about three four
years and then probably six months ago
seven months ago I quit that job to do
YouTube because they got to a point to
where I wanted to do more
or be a little more in depth with my
content right and like I said I kind of
do my own thing on YouTube right I just
find something that I like and I want to
talk about it and there's certain things
that I mean it like that's got rifle
from gambit like I'll review it and like
I'm like it's not good right I won't -
if it doesn't need to be hyped right but
yeah I do know that there's a lot of
like oh my go
like when war mine came out we still had
static roles there was the forgone
conclusion was a high impact they are
like I need a date on that
I was like why are you reviewing the
fork on conclusion I'm like here's deal
and like my wife's perfect example right
before guy conclusions like their gun
like they get it they love it there are
people that like guns that aren't
technically good but like that's that's
it baby
there baby right so like well let's at
least talk about
and why it's good and why you probably
like it but there's why the issues that
it has right so I always do kind of
off-the-wall things when I can to a
schedule I try to do at least now three
or four videos a week but it's just
getting the gameplay and then of course
the production of all that it just takes
so long I can only imagine you're
editing timeline is rather meticulous as
well so I live for it though I love
those timelines it is it was you run and
so you said two monitors you got what
like you're gonna ultra-wide in there if
you're editing you're just like - pretty
sizable ones sizable I use Asus I love a
sis's monitor so I'm staring at two of
them right now so I'm with ya 27 that's
mine
oh man yeah we could definitely do a
whole tech podcast I think on the side
of it because I sit here net I look
through so so what is your current queue
because you said what is your computer
right now you're running on I'm surely
curious cuz you said some of the videos
I know you started they were really slow
but what are you currently running right
now for your since it's a little more a
full-time gig since they got to get
production a little cold hours all I do
with my computer is edit and it does
what I needed to do it's an i7 you know
actual specs on it and you'd be proud of
me I literally know nothing like I said
we talked about missed an Oregon Trail
earlier like I don't really know that
much about my own ram last month and I
guys relations there Lucas man though
don't feel don't feel too bad I had to
give kognito a little hard Tahoe and
when he was like he sent me a picture be
like so what are these and I'm just
sitting here going those the rim but I
was like but I was like I know you know
it but you're likewise all glowy is like
is this the right I'm like yeah like I
haven't built a rig I'm owed for the
record so it's been like over plus 10
you know saying is that I've even built
a rig so it's like I'm so antiquated so
I'm like damn this thing's all going up
now and like where you put the dam and
SSD at like y'all just shouting that
feel my way around I'm like 'hey here's
my board
where do I stick this thing I need some
space for these games my specs here like
that's how bad I am my graphics card
like they don't make it anymore it's in
a video like 720 or something like it's
it can't read destiny that's all right
now like my yeah my computer sitting
there's my good ones over here my other
ones on my left sitting on the floor
still and that's my 760 sitting on the
floor and that was I knew as soon as I
started playing and then I tried to hit
the record button on PC capture and it
just shut like basically stopped work
and I was like nope can't do this on the
same rig so nope I had a yeah my
investment was my rig over on my right
so that's uh it it Rico I can record and
play and stream all in the same box
which is yeah that's like I've thought
about maybe like doing streams to maybe
raise one for rig like because like
hammy cakes and he has no kami right
like yeah and like everyday for a year
and a half I played with kami right and
we were two peas but then he went to the
dark side right you mean the master race
he left you by bunch of us you know the
lowest population of the game but anyway
like dude you know I'll help you juice
he'll help you we get people you know to
get you a stream goal that way see but I
don't know man like play destiny at 60
frames one time that was Guardian kanwa
giving me water and like I'll never
forget it like it felt so good I'm like
this is my yeah this is this is where
the eyes have been opened yeah see see
I'm when she brought that I I purposely
chose to stay ignorant because I knew
what would happen
I knew playing it any level of things
it's over and that's what happened they
literally went free-to-play
what was it last November yeah yeah like
that
yes I'm like last November it was like
right around black frightening even
vaunteth history of he's like excuse now
everybody he's like hey I had to get a
rig because I was like again I'm running
with a you know a ten year old potato
and so you know trying to do podcast and
doing stuff so I needed a rig just to
step up my podcast game and start to you
know to grow the channel and I'm like
all right he's right I got to do it so
I'm like all right spec me out something
just you know only thing I'm willing to
go crazy is TP you and be reasonable
with every other thing so II you know he
had kid gloves will be he's fight really
I don't know you don't have to you're
gonna have to do all right all right so
we made some compromises and I got it
but I'm telling you right now CG it's
the way it is so night and they just the
field of view alone just this altering
that it's just like it's just the way
it's supposed to be played it's buttery
smooth it's amazing and then now with
cross save it's like okay you know if I
want to play with my guys I can easily
do that you know in September like that
so that's the only thing that hurt the
most was just like you know the majority
of your friends and stuff like that you
got to make new friends you know I'm
saying and luckily I got he shout out to
a Wilhelm scream shout out to pyro
you know those guys they're very helpful
very helpful and um you know once you
find yourself a little crude at least
you got a couple people to do activity
with but for the most part man you'll be
so Owen and rocking out and having fun
in your own little glorious world yeah I
do need to get it at some point man I've
always thought about it I don't know
with controller and no you see me out
here control the gang and I'm your top
elite controller you're good to go man
and with Game Boy whoa just press my
button record you got all my options
love it yeah I would say cept I'm gonna
do it CG boys September yeah it was like
you come and you guess it's not a clean
break yeah you still have that
association you go back and forth well
I'll probably get with you guys to help
me out putting something together
that's that's what it was like for me
that I live for like I loved building
computers and I only get to do it every
like four or five I don't get to do it
that often so when I get to build one or
somebody else wants to build one it's
like I'll help please can help I'll
build it for you just let me build the
parts like I would literally build it
and ship it to somebody like if somebody
would let so like I don't know it's just
one of those things like putting all the
pieces together and that's my like ultra
nerdy moment is like building computers
but I have an absolute blast doing it so
I've had a couple I have a couple people
in Twitter they'll be like hey what it
was like well what's your budget what do
you want okay here's what I can try and
build and honestly with like AMD coming
out with this stuff it literally like a
week or two they're gonna definitely put
some game changers out there for if
nothing else just to give Intel some
competition so now things are getting to
a point where it's good for both sides
so it's like Nvidia still got the
graphics cards that you want but like
CPUs and competition it's it's all good
things going right now so so it's a good
time to be a tech nerd and have fun and
enjoy all the stadia build a computer
have cross save and use your controller
because apparently mouse and keyboard
just isn't your thing that's office
console guys really tough man I've
always wondered how I would do with it
because I've never tried really like you
it takes some time to get used to like
I've been doing it off and on for I've
been playing like Rainbow six with like
an old-ass computer over dial-up like I
played that with a buddy of mine like so
I've been using them both for so long I
feel like it's just kind of I'm probably
almost I'm mediocre at both because
people could whoop you know mop the
floor with me on PC probably all day
long and I'm sure you'll beat the crap
out of me with a controller on PC too so
you can just kind of laugh at me it'll
be like how's that mouse and keyboard
treating you while you're dead that's
gonna be fine how's the is there any lag
on PC not much man that's one of the
other things too is I'll be kind of
curious when that's one of the other
things I guess when talking we talk
about d3 that we didn't even get to is
like dedicated servers that's the one I
know everybody like for you for console
for PC like whatever it is like there
are and I I'm I know my skill level not
in the top not in the bottom of the
barrel I'm somewhere kind of in the okay
range but I know there are games I will
jump into and it's it is that point
where it's like in cool-guy if you can
you know comment on this to like you're
probably good most of the time but there
are times when like I'm hitting so many
of my shots and it's like I feel like
somebody on my team is probably the host
and I'm doing better and then sometimes
it'll flip and then I'm like I can't hit
the broad side of a wall or something
like there are moments where that flip
happens that I think dedicated servers
is one of the major ones and that's one
of those who are I wonder like the
stadia population if you're playing on
stadia there is no way to host it you're
on there they're hosting it so that's I
think one of the big questions for
stadia that'll be do you feel I mean
your skeletal evel's probably so how you
probably don't but do you have do you
have those feelings of where you like
you know somebody on your teams hosting
or your hosting you know do you get
those like dynamics of games where it
feels good and feels like trash I do
yeah
so peer to peer matchmaking is just so
it's in the past like is because how it
works because like people like well you
know this games lag and you know I have
you know Google Fiber and people just
gonna have something like it it doesn't
really matter what your internet is
because what else right so it goes even
further with skill based matchmaking
like so when I used to play destiny I
was like I was top 400 top 300 top
hundred whatever top hundred and Rumble
so I play games from like high right so
you started doing peer-to-peer that
skill based is starting to connect your
your skill like with people across the
ocean and lag I'm like and I'm trying to
kill the guy I'm like well this is the
the last guy like this is a guy that has
like you know well dial up internet
cards like he day to be in my game right
you're 250 hours free on your CD we all
just hated ourselves by the way big time
yeah we've all dated out so hardcore
April I mistake a channel okay which was
rising as a kid like how does that even
work but
the good ol icloud play like I'm all
about the game running properly dude's
like when there's that type of lag
introduced when you're skilling people
in different continents in the games
lagging and there's a clear obvious
advantage like it isn't running properly
so dedicated servers is the answer and
dedicated servers you there's like no
ddossing because if you try to DDoS on a
dedicated server you DDoS yourself like
how many layers to it right mmm huge
hey maybe able to get with Amazon our
baby sister with Google now right maybe
yeah maybe maybe what Azure would a
Sony's own in bed dare to using those
servers for next generation so teaming
up against Adia exactly got to those are
I guess I used my Game of Thrones
references the state is like the the
White Walkers you got a beautiful dogs
and cats sleep together you got to fight
the walkers man they're coming that's a
whole lot of references in one sentence
right there I like that yeah so like
that's kind of one of those for me
that's always annoying because I'll play
all I'm I literally live at like one
point for 3k TANF that's like just so
probably about a 1.0 and I'm just like I
have loved some downs I feel like I do
okay I have some decent games and I'm
like hey and it's and it's been I think
most apparent as I've been working on
revoke her because sniping is so you hit
him or you don't like the misses are
very appearance not like hey I'm just a
bullet on my go figure it took a little
longer to kill him
you miss your don't all have games I'll
go and it's like I just got to crispy
kills I'm actually feeling good like
maybe this will be at a higher a
light-rail in the next game I just get
stepped on and trashed and like I can't
shoot anybody and those so when like on
PC it's still there like but I would say
it seems better for sure the loading
times are like night and day just put
you a fast hard drive in there you'll
feel it like there are certain things
about PC like that's needs who's still
gonna have but everything on PC is still
gonna be better in general for loading
times the field of Oh frames per second
all those things are gonna be worth the
upgrade and especially if you're going
full time like you know 6 some of those
YouTube checks away and be like right I
got a budget let me knock out this
really cool because if you already got
two monitors your half you
basically there anyway you got the you
got that part out of the way that it's
just a box that powers it on yourself
only advice I would give you to being it
you know you play a lot of PvP is that
um don't step in there until you have
your loadout till you have you said your
weapons now the yeah the adjustment from
that's true to cross say me right
but the adjustment from arm I think the
biggest adjustment I had to deal with
was that you feel the level of accuracy
when you're facing a mouse and keyboard
guy and you're gonna know when not to
challenge like okay you're about to
engage like I'm late or you know and you
have to get out of it you have to get
your ego out of it cuz the accuracy you
do feel it
but once you get your doubts and smart
play and you know your your tactic you
can mean more than fun you can be more
than fine but when you play sweats you
you'll feel it because then you'll
definitely feel there's no doubt about
it but to me it makes me better I love
it I love to challenge and I love when I
see a few times and I'm at the top that
I'm like okay aren't that you know
saying like I'm doing my thing out yeah
I will say fall out when he looks for
his research assistance when cross save
is there he's gonna have about 6,000
more tweet replies because everybody's
gonna be like me I'm here no cuz I'd
said like right now he'll be like hey
who wants to get shot in the face right
now I'd be like I would I'm on the wrong
console you'd be like right now I'd be
like are you coming to PC or do I have
to go over to ps4 what do we do it like
the cross savings gonna have so many
cool moments for just stuff like that
that I can't wait for and even if you're
normally on xbox which you've got a rig
that's decent like you throw honestly
for you like if you throw a graphics
card in if you got an i7 that's almost
probably all you need if you just put
RAM in there to like you wouldn't need a
lot to get started and if you just spend
some money on a graphics card now and be
like okay I got a hella graphics card
it's pretty even probably a little much
if you want to upgrade later that'll
last you a while so there's different
ways for you to go for upgrades that
aren't like let me build an entire thing
from case motherboard bottom up if you
just do a graphics card and that might
even work for you a cool buy this turned
into apparently a Tech Talk sorry
everybody yeah message what a big cool
guy that he sent you a message
discord oh hold on mm-hmm I can't see
discord because it's fullscreen yeah can
I see BRB oh yeah he'll be right back
okay cool no but yeah I was like
honestly it's been like the switch to PC
for you has been fun to watch because I
know you gave me a hard time you waited
for a while but now that you're here and
you're like alright fine still using my
controller though so I'm holding it's
been good it's been good I really really
enjoyed it I'm fully you know
indoctrinated there's no going back
it is there right now but um oh I'll be
there I'll play a couple more once the
new next-gen stuff comes out but again
I'll be gone oh man I love it I love it
it's really cool you know and um I'm
just excited I'm excited for that player
base man Society to see people come over
beside of more people playing with each
other you know it's gonna do so much for
the game September cannot wait
cannot wait yeah I will there will be
ups and downs to it I think because for
the ups you'll have a like a population
for things like crucible and gambit
you'll have a lot more people in there
and kind of leveling the playing field
for kind of difficulty not everybody's
gonna be ultra sweaty cuz that's all the
people that are playing but in turn
you're gonna have people in strikes
who don't know what the hell to do
you're gonna people in public events
that don't know what a heroic is like
there's gonna be a lot of learning for
the new people and people's Butera be
like oh cool what's this let me shoot
this guy real quick and like no clue
what's going on and yeah like there will
be some some veteran frustrations I can
see on the PvE side of things but then
in PvP people like man like Katie's
going up and up and I'm like look at
these games of like 40 kills me saying
40 kills is gonna be a whole bunch of
noobs in the other side so stuff like
that's gonna happen but love it love it
massive fight I'll bellman I'm gonna be
on like a I don't he saw em - he's got
like an air air until yep yeah as fusion
rifle that's busted oh my god it's how
Arius I won't if I could get I'm gonna
have a couple moments like that I get a
couple a few it'll be good just to laugh
okay now I feel better about myself
swaying Newberry's that's probably about
how like I mean like cool guy who
stepped away I mean he'll be back like
cool guy emtashval when they're play and
they're just like they're just working
people constantly and like that'll be
those I don't get those feelings often
when like the cards fall right maybe but
yeah with a lot bigger player base
hopefully and hopefully a few more
rounds under my belt than they've got it
should feel pretty good so absolutely
cannot wait cannot wait
yeah gonna be some nice content in
September I'm actually about that good
yeah we're just kind of rambling about
like with new light players coming I was
saying like pvp populations gonna have
some easy blueberries to shoot and I was
gonna say like running strikes or public
events is probably gonna make you want
to pull your hair out so it's gonna be
both with the new population but yeah I
know we've had the thing don't kill the
captain yeah so we need be heroic yes
what's heroic that's like I I feel like
that's one of those videos I have to
make like heroic public events are you
new make sure you like it's that's got
to be one of the ones it's like learn
what heroic public events are here
here's the like nearest those awesome
graphics for it like you all these
things there's a lot of resources but
look if you're gonna play this game
don't piss off the veterans it's like
we'll help you but you gotta try it a
little bit did feel I felt a lot of that
when I first went over to PC lates well
you got on at the same time everything
was free right yeah that's it I'm
putting myself in that mentality come
September because literally that's what
it was I'm like stop shoot I'm losing a
mopes like no shooting what are you
doing you got a laugh oh yeah I'll be
brand new so well cougar um we will try
and wrap this thing up but before we go
well the questions we do ask all of our
guests and since it sounds like you've
been playing destiny since forever like
us
we've been I was alpha were you alpha
kognito you get it how about you cool
guide you getting the alpha not I was
beta beta okay fine
beta alpha board before it launched is
kind of the point we've been in this
thing since it's a PC or in the alpha
keep going I know and cool guys over
there like channels bigger KD than you
know it's fine I'm so glad that the
exclusives were gone man because as an
Xbox player PC PlayStation Sega
Dreamcast SNES Xbox like it was like
that's how you reviewed so I mean we're
all we're all on the same page now
I'm excited citizen Jade rabbits
well that was the thing like as soon as
PC launched for destiny to I went to it
and that's when I was like well I guess
I won't be talking about PlayStation 4
exclusive for a while because I I
literally been on PlayStation that's
where I'd been and then I jumped in PC
and I was like oh yeah that's the thing
I didn't think about it until a little
while ago so Xbox guys was suffering bro
no idea was it was tough out here cool
god no it was - I'll never forget
real quick tangent um taking King they
had was it [ __ ] Jade rabbit Zen meteor
Zen meteor yep and there were a couple
of maps and a couple of suits and I'm
like alright as an ex rock god you got
used to it you're like okay we're gonna
get that you know the next DLC you know
whatever IX look here whatever like a
year but you like okay I'll deal with it
and I believe it was rise of iron so I'm
sitting there like yeah I'm ready for my
Jade rabbit and then I'll never forget
like DS got on stream and these guys got
a machine they were like you know it's
not happening you know and it got
extended like another year
they didn't expose guys did not get
those guns until d2 came out like are
you kidding me right now like this is oh
that was painful bro and then we got
home late like the worst one was the
hawk my man completely you know you know
exactly
you know we never experienced it in its
hey like don't you know the Magic Bullet
man it hurt it was tough to be expose
God for destiny but you just stuck with
it man I think content creation like
destiny comes out you know and then my
new videos alright guys we're talking
about the Jade rabbit today like like
two years ago and you're like yep that's
just brand new for me so we're covering
oh it's brand new
mm-hmm it's brand new for me but the
question is with the long history that
you've got see if you can come up with
your top three just for you top three
moments in your experience of all of
destiny hmm Owens would be the beta
there was the the queue of 60,000 people
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah indeed what's
this you know when they open up the moon
right yep that was to this day that's
why I'm so excited they're bringing back
the new man because like if you go back
into y1 and just look at the sky you see
the satellites the shootings like it's
just so cool and then like in like as
Luke Smith is saying right now like I'll
never forget that nice would be on a
personal note and run in YouTube with
destiny just you know kind of see in
what I wanted to talk about and there
was so much there's way more depth in in
the weapons and destiny one which is a
shame mmhmm yeah that but true yeah
because there was so much you could do
with the weapons nd one and the third
one would probably be my first raid
clear and that was vault of glass salute
it's not always by the console player
I've never done anything like that
mmm well doing an activity like that I
guess I'll never forget it right well I
I got it I got a cut you one say because
you bring a feels cool guy bring it
feels I think you nailed it because that
was literally the moment that hooked me
into the game I played the campaign I
was done with it I was
that impressed with destiny and um I
would never forget me like no get to
level 30 and I grind it out and I fall
to glass was that moment and at that
point I've never done a six man activity
that was coordinated and he just had all
these things involved with it blew my
mind I was like this this is next-level
I've never experienced this but continue
to you know that was a great moment like
crack ban like as I remember like it was
so fun and rewarding right yeah we
granted you know you're forever 29 you
know you didn't get the boots or
whatever was the hell like mine was the
helm forever mm-hmm but that raid I mean
there was feet wringer there was there
was all these different weapons that
were tight of course the VEX vision
there's no room and the crucible 452
headshot bags but just doing that
especially is someone like me cuz like I
play a lot of crucible and when I play
crucible I play alone a lot because for
the gameplay I try to get like raw
versus I mean when I play with people or
someone messages me I'll [ __ ] with them
if I'm not doing anything I'll play with
them right so like a subscriber like a
fan a very really sick stack but like
players that I play with I've been
playing with for about eight to ten
years there's about seven of us eight of
us we all know each other very very well
been to all of our weddings right um so
that was the first time we ever did
something like that together and like
that's what got us as a group hooked on
destiny nice facts that community man
that's what he did that yeah well those
are on Italy yeah those are all three so
you got you know the beta the radar than
YouTube and those are legit I know we've
had ours before as well but it's like
the experience as you say it's like this
game does things that pretty much
nothing else does and that's one like
everybody who talks about those whether
it's like we had market Guardian con
talking about just like first
experiences and just like him in the
podcast and stuff like that for you and
your YouTube channel for us in the
podcast and a lot of every a lot of what
we get to see is the community building
something
than they ever expected it would be yeah
absolutely absolutely and a final point
like what you said he too is um another
nice touch was loading destiny to and
seeing those kind of flashback
remembrance kind of sequences of who was
in your fireteam yeah and you completed
stuff and you know is a couple people
unfortunately that you know no longer on
this earth they passed away but it
really hit me because I'm like wow I
remember that I remember when we did
that rig remember this person Wow
and you forged those lifelong friendship
you know opting me you with the last
word of it you know basically because of
Guardian con you know I know people I
remember I did Oryx hard and I'm shout
to Frodo he's in my clan like I've known
him for five years like it I turned I
like do we went to Vietnam to get but
like or eat our bull was like that was
it for me like it was I was such a
struggle to get that ring cleared for my
first time and like he was on that team
you remember you form that bond that
trust with that person and it is the
memories again is there's a lot of good
games but in my opinion like that's what
destiny does better than any other game
it's just that community bringing people
together and those who remember yeah so
I don't know if we can top it better
than that for an ending so cool guy it
has been awesome to have you on you
obviously of course are always welcome
anytime you want to chat we love talking
about destiny and being nerdy of course
so ya know it was our pleasure
absolutely so for those who are
listening you just want to tell them
where to find you what you got working
on anything you got coming in the future
you know where to find you at Guardian
Colin apparently besides the you know
keep an eye out for you at least I won't
reveal any secrets or anything yeah so
my youtube channel is youtube.com
backslash cool guy tips mm-hmm and on
Twitter I am cool guy whitey I try to
post as much as I can now I do have a
twitch channel it's I underscore
underscore cool guy the way I do YouTube
like I don't have time for it and I want
to be able to the point where I can
stream or because I love
screaming dude I love talking with
people I'm playing but it was that's my
main thing and of course a guardian con
if you find me I have stickers of
magnets for you so power nice very nice
awesome stuff so yeah find this man he
puts out amazing content he will show
you things that you never thought you
should be using he's gonna show you that
they're better than probably what you
think is good so he's gonna give you
some good things look at excellent
content Cognito of course as well for
you always putting in lots of work in
many facets what do you got coming up
sir ya know a lot of stuff up on Lords
of gaming dotnet right now so I could
say to check it out I've got a little
article on the destiny cross same
situation and just you know roadmap for
the future and my thoughts on that
obviously you know the YouTube channel a
little podcast please every Sunday is
the Lord's Day 1:00 p.m. Eastern this
week we will be taking a break as you
know I'm gonna be traveling yeah yes in
and then I believe Sava has some travel
stuff so we're gonna take a break this
Sunday but we will return you don't
saying next Sunday hopefully and yeah
we're gonna have some big gas you know
some industry people of course I'm
working on some game developers and also
some other arm executives so look out
for that we got some fun stuff planned
and on the channel you know king of
statues look King he's if you're a
statue guy you love that kind of stuff
please check it out and then of course
the last word I mean II just talking
that Luther shooter talk like he do a
little a ton of it being 90% of it being
destiny yeah we were like all looter
shooters we had anthem coming and then
death and then division was gonna come
and we're basically just talking about
destiny again so that was short-lived
it's the Phoenix me anything rises every
single time like it looks bleak and then
you know Adam doesn't survive all the
quote unquote definitely killers don't
end up surviving it goes definitely
right back and it looks like it's
getting only looks like it's truly going
an amazing direction I think so
absolutely and then for me you guys all
know where to find me it's Yvonne test
everywhere eb o and t is if you find the
cheetah you found me we will be at
Guardian Con and I'm looking forward to
it there are so many people it's like
I want to shake your hands like looking
forward to meeting like a lot of people
that have actually liked in the past
kind of year or so since things have
kind of started to blow up and stuff
like that to be just a little bit more
like hi like hello I'm this guy just
like and shakes so many people saying
it's like get to do like destiny
community podcast like you've been on
there right - a cool guy I'm pretty sure
because I feel like you have the CS I've
spoken with them
yeah so but I was like I usually can
tell cuz like you look at people's
Twitter profiles and they're like
Facebook is the one that Ash did for you
oh my I have that framed on my wall I
was so I was so proud to eat when he's
on nobody like cuz it was so funny I
talked to her about the art that she
does I was like you do such an amazing
job every time and then it was just a
Twitter DM I sent it to her and she
replied back and was just like hey the
content you do is great - thanks for
helping out the solo players I was like
I'm sorry excuse me what like I was like
I'm still at the point of like I don't
know I don't think people know me
because I don't think they do so it's
one of those that's it's really cool to
kind of go out there and hopefully just
like meet a lot of people but honestly
like there's so many Bungie devs that
are going I feel like I'm just gonna
like park a chair at their table and
just like I want to talk to him all for
like a day so no Guardian Khan is gonna
be a whole lot of fun this Hitler year
and I think I'll be broke from buying
art from some of these artists out there
you should have never showed me that
artist so like Brian Monk Asst his has
been crazy there's so many out I can't
even list them all there's one I'd have
to look through and scroll through
they've done like it's a graphic of like
kind of shorter character type three
Guardians in the background is kind of
the theme one of them was last with wish
with a little ribbon behind and then oh
there's but it's like the list of
destiny artists just goes and goes like
Belle what is it Mary but I can't
everything of her name - she's got some
really cool ones yeah Bellmare bye bye
mall but she's got some awesome there's
so many like will and won't be there but
it's like between blind people drinks
buying are back there and just saying
hello like I'm gonna be broke and
exhausted and it's gonna be awesome it's
gonna be lost
Broly we back together I know dude I
haven't seen you and literally that
since yeah four years ago now man it to
me cool guy no but you guys if you guys
want man oh absolutely man shoutout to
I'm looking forward to uh cactus so it's
like traveled up with em fallout plays
no dzp tissue I know a lot of those guys
Messi Holtz I am a big host fanboy so
you actually doing some with Bungie
right I think he's contract tester
everybody's back up there he's doing
that yeah just it's it's an amazing
community and we probably can't say it
enough and like any time you were to me
like hey do you want to come on the
podcast cool it's like it's two hours
you're like dude I can talk about
destiny for a while like nobody nobody
seems to usually mind they may not know
like how long it's gonna go and you may
be like okay I'm done I'm tired to talk
to you guys that's cool but like two and
a half hours later it's like we can we
can always go so it's been an absolute
pleasure so thank you very much we try
and time this thing but with delays and
everything it's always terrible we
always try and say and this has been and
we just finished with the last word so
there's usually a delay so I'll try and
match you guys but when I say it has
been and then you guys try and say it
together for the last word I'll try and
match you so alright guys for episode 64
it has been amazing to have cool guy on
here Lord cognate of course of the on
Lords podcasts and for this episode it
has been the last word